Is Our whole new setup. We're an
ht now you're gonna look beautiful.
I don't need, I need to not HD.
I need like cheese cloth Vaseline
in HD. We got multicolored look at the
colors, different colors for the buttons.
Now that's huge.
When you get lit up colors.
That's what I thought the future was
gonna look like when there's computers and
like 2015 I thought it would be like
the inside of like a space ship.
Is that what Star Trek? Yeah,
like multicolored. All buttons.
That is how, right? That's the tricaster.
So we're in HD now. Your beautiful baby.
You're beautiful. Look
at you. You're beautiful.
Oh fuck. I need hair. Him.
Where's my hair and makeup?
What's going on, man? You
fucking savage. World Traveler.
You're the most savage world traveler.
I know you're the do.
And I'll get a text message from you and
you're in fucking Bulgaria or some shit.
You're in North Korea on some wacky
cell systems. The communists. You, your,
your
well, what? I didn't text you from North
Korea because they won't let me. But, uh,
yeah, I was just in Antarctica and
the South Pole. That's hard to get to.
Very hard to get
do.
You were one of the,
your special was one of the first things
that I ever saw on North Korea that
made me like really start to investigate
it. Like I knew that they had,
there was a lot of human rights
violations in this horrible,
the things that they're
doing to people in prisons,
but I want you going to
those fake restaurants and
having these people take you
around and trying to present you with
this image of what North Korea is like.
Like oh, it's just like everywhere else
coming here. And you were like really,
you know, talking about it pretty
openly on camera while you were there.
And that made me really
like start to look into it.
And this is before all this shit has
gone down with the interview of course.
And before the poor people really,
I think like after his dad died, that's
when people really got a sense of like,
well this is not going to end
here if this crazy communist,
this is like the last
real crazy communistic
tater. Yeah. Like the old school
sort of Utopian Communist,
a cult of personality. Their God
there, you know the president,
they're the, they're, you know George
Washington there, everything. And uh,
yeah, it's still going on, which
is is crazy. In fact, they,
they pick Kim Jong UN cause he looked
like his grandfather came in the song and
so the people were like, oh, you know,
they're the same guy kind of thing.
It's so we, I mean I was always,
I'm one of those people that uh,
I'll get something on my head and then
that will be stuck in my head for weeks
and weeks and weeks for a long time
was the Mongols and people like to,
but you just shut the fuck up about the
Mongols and I wouldn't see that movie.
Mongol. Yeah, I did. So good. Pretty
good. So no, it's really good man.
Marco Polo on check it out. Yeah.
It deals with cu black Kahn.
Who's like the descendants, the
grandson of of Genghis Khan. Yes. Yeah.
I suppose I always had gangas Jengas but
then I got into North Korea after your
show, after watching you and that
restaurant calling like weird short raid.
This is the government's putting
on a charade for journalists.
And also I was thinking like they fucking,
they kitten have people like you go
in there and do and that was pretty
dangerous.
Yeah.
There's another film. Um, we, we
interviewed the woman actually,
I think they just sold the rights
were they're making the film.
It's a crazy story of,
um,
there was like basically the
Orson Welles of South Korea.
So after the war they had this crazy
film scene going on in South Korea and
there was like the Orson Welles and
like the hottest start at their Marilyn
Monroe basically.
Right.
And there were husband and wife and they
ended up getting into a fight and the
wife goes to Japan, she's crying, she's
pissed off, she goes to Tokyo, boom,
disappears. Right. And it only can
find, or what the fuck's going on.
So he goes to Tokyo, boom, he disappears.
Now it turns out they were kidnapped by
the North Koreans, right? By Kim Il Sung.
Yeah. And so they had made this film
studio, which I actually went to.
It's a complete replica of 20th Century
Fox back in the 50s and they make all
these anti American films.
Anyway, it turned out that
the woman who key kidnapped,
he turned into sort of a a sex slave
and the star of all these North Korean
propaganda movies,
cause he used to make a ton of movies.
They get the husband and say, now you're
going to direct her in these movies,
right? They kidnapped him in Tokyo. And he
said, fuck you, I'm not going to do that.
So they had put them in a concentration
camp, which a Korean concentration camp,
maybe the worst place in the world.
So he's eating grass and he's
being tortured five years, right.
Five fucking years. He's in this
concentration camp. Finally he says, okay,
I'll do it.
I'll direct the films.
So they let him out and he
goes to Kim Jong UN's palace.
Uh, and then all of a sudden, uh,
there's his wife and his wife all
of a sudden realizes, holy shit,
he's a alive be. He came to get me, see,
he's been in the concentration
camp and he realizes, oh,
she's been eating shrimp pattern
all day. Fucking GIM junk. He'll,
while I'm in the concentration camp,
in any case,
they get together and make like seven
movies, big movies for North Korea.
And in fact, one of them
called escape, no joke,
called escape get wins.
A Moscow like Oscar,
like a Soviet Oscar at the time as
a reward, they get to go to Vienna,
which was their dream because it's where
the third man was, was uh, was uh, filmed.
He then, and she [inaudible] their
tour of Vienna. They get their labs.
We were allowed to tour of Vienna. They
defect and they get out. And finally they,
because they escape and then he,
they told the story and now
they're making a movie about it.
So they're probably going to shut that.
Whoever puts out,
I'm just going to get shut down to
fuck.
That is the craziest story. Yeah, true
story. Yeah. Can still live like that.
I mean that's, that's basically the same
as people lived 5,000 years ago. I mean,
Shit, kidnapping, Peter, forcing
the wife to be a sex slave,
forcing the husband to a concentration
camp, torturing him, starving him.
Yeah. It's completely
insane. Whenever you,
whenever you start dealing with North
Korea at a, in any level about anything
crazy as fuck, it's just amazing that
it's still around like that. Yeah,
it is. She's such a, it's such an
archaic idea. I mean, it really is.
It doesn't fit in what we think
of as 2015 the modern world,
although it wasn't that long ago,
you know that you had style in his Russia,
you had Maoist China, you had Hitler's
Germany where people just went, Yep,
that's the dude. He's the one who tells
us how to do everything, you know?
But it's,
I think it's really disturbing because
it's happening now and even though like
40 years ago or 50 years ago,
isn't it really that long ago?
Right now it feels like that could be us.
But I think if you look at what's
happening in Russia's not so far away,
because obviously the, the, the thing
about North Korea, which is weird,
is it's like going back to 1938 you know,
it's like going back in time.
But the thing about rush, if you
go to Russia now, they're like,
there is no economic crisis.
America did this to us,
the oil is falling because
America did this to us. It's,
it's total cold war rhetoric.
And, and, and Putin is, you know,
the news are, he's, he's, he's taken
over all power and he, you know,
he runs the press and you know, he
runs everything and, and it, it,
it's definitely not going forward
in Russia. It's going backwards.
Yeah. He's a weird case, isn't he? I mean,
it's just so blatant that
this guy is a dictator.
When you see what happens when there's
any sort of dispute over there,
and even with these
oligarchs takes them out.
They put him in jail and they
take their businesses. Yeah, sure.
And he's done this more than once,
right.
Did it to a guy recently and he only
wound up taking one of his oil businesses.
Yeah. And you know, he's done it with,
with famously with Gazprom and Rosneft,
um, where, you know,
one guy became the richest dude in the
world and three other guys got either
assassinated or went to jail. So I think
that when you look at it, you know, uh,
it's a tough place to do
business. Russia, unless you're,
unless you got a key card to the Kremlin,
you're not going to get anything done.
I mean, it's so blatant. It's
so blatant. It's so strange.
They just reactivated 28,
28 Cold War bases this year.
So they were done. Okay.
Cold War's over, you have luck. We're
done. Boom. 28 basis reactivated like, ah,
what,
what do you think that they feel like
the only way to recharge the economy is
being a full blown conflict
with the United States.
And I think that it was a
humiliation in Russia. Um, you know,
we look at sort of Gorbachev and
Yeltsin and go, oh, you know,
they finally came to their senses and
joined the world and whatever, you know,
Yeltsin drank a bit too much
or whatever. But uh, there,
that's seen as a huge humiliation
as we, you know, we were at,
if not number one,
we were number two for a long time.
And then we went to being
an also ran and that was a,
it was a lot of resentment there. A
B, then as oil came on the ascendancy,
they're like, okay, we're going
to throw our weight around.
So they were subsidizing oil, for
example, Cuba was subsidized. Well,
you know, one of the reasons why they're
like, oh, let's be friends again,
is there's no more oil sipes subsidies
and it's the same thing in, in,
in the region. And then I think what
happened is Putin came along and said,
Russia is the best again and we're going
to fuck with people and we're going to
take back our land that they took from
us and we're going to take back this and
our military the best.
And we're going to put more money in the
military and we're going to reactivate
these bases. And people went,
yeah, good. Why not? By the
way, you've got to remember,
you've got to remember too,
that
grew up where we were the boogie
man. So it's not too like, you know,
all the old people, like if you look at
the Fox News, people that are like, yeah,
fuck we run Roger those.
They're all comedies. Well,
all the people in Russia are going, I know
the Americans eat the babies, you know,
and, and so it's not that
much of a stretch. Well,
and if you look at like
the way we behave abroad,
I mean the fact that we
have multiple wars going on,
that we have a drone on their,
on their border,
we look scary as fuck to say
outside of us. Remember that?
Remember that sting song? Uh, the
Russians love their children too. Yeah.
He's a great song. Yeah. Yeah. I remember
listening to that song and thinking,
was it Stinger? The police might
have been, I think it was staying.
I think it was when his sounds like
staying, but it was the era of the police.
Yeah. Um, and he was, I mean,
we thought of them like that
there was going to kill everybody.
It was through this going
to be a nuclear war.
The Russians were going to kill anybody.
It hovered over our head all the time.
Well, you and I grew up at the end of
the Cold War when it was still full on.
Yeah.
It's propaganda shit.
You ever watched like war games and
like that was just a given. Yeah,
of course we're going to destroy each
other. It's just a matter of time.
And then when you get to school and you
find out about the Cuban missile crisis
and go, wait, but how close was
that? Oh fuck man. Wait a minute.
What we're going to go to nuclear
war with? For what? Yeah. Holy Shit.
The idea is that that almost
happened or could sprays up and,
or even like step one and a three
step process of happening. Yeah.
It's completely
Leah Insane. And we had this small
interim of sanity where we all went,
those guys were crazy. It's a good
thing. We're not like that anymore.
And now we're going. Yeah, we still
have all those warheads pointed at them.
They still have all those warheads pointed
it at us. And you're like, well, why?
It really is amazing if you think about
how long people have been alive for,
it really is amazing that we've only
dropped two nuclear bombs since 1947 yeah,
I mean just those two. Yeah. And
that was it. Well, there were bad,
so they scared the shit out of that.
But everything else we keep doing,
everything else is fucked up.
We keep doing it.
But that was the one thing that we ever
did that was so brutal and so real.
There was no way of
morally like rationalize.
Well, even us at our craziest, and even
the Russians at their craziest, you know,
we never did it, but the problem is is
we were rational actors. We were like,
even if we hated each other,
and even if there was propaganda,
we're still rational actors.
The problem,
the worry is you have irrational actors,
like Pakistan has over a hundred war
warheads and they're rapidly becoming an
irrational act because they're losing
control over their country to the Taliban
who you know, who, who are are,
whose agenda is clearly stated
that they want to fuck us up.
So I mean that's, that's where it
gets terrified, but we shouldn't,
it's the New Year Joe. We
shouldn't start. We should get,
we shouldn't get straight into like,
you know,
and w and the vector for war had
number six one seven nine is Carmel,
California.
I had these conversations with you more
than anybody I know because you're the
one that you're the one who actually
goes to these fucking places. You,
you actually go, well I will say creepy,
scary spots and coming back with news.
But you know,
I used to be afraid of,
of why know I go with all these war
zones and I still am. But you know,
war is bad. Everyone always says, well,
we go to war and they picture sort of
manly GI Joe type shooting each other and
it generally doesn't look like that.
It's lots of collateral damage and women
and children being fucking blown to
shit and then guys go in there and
get PTSD and get their ass shot off.
But you know, the thing is, is one of the
things that I recently came back from,
it fucked me up. Like really? I mean,
now I'm to the point where I'm having
a kind of an existential crisis going,
well, what's it all mean is I went to
the South Pole because we did this,
we did this piece on Greenland melting,
which one is the Emmy last year?
We got a lot of uh, uh, whatever, uh,
discussion around it on both sides
of, of the, uh, of the debate.
Although why it's a fucking
debate, I don't know. But anyway,
the Arctic is melting.
One of the things that's happening,
the reason why the Cold War is heating
up again as the, under the Arctic ice,
there's tons of oil and gas and Russia
doesn't have any other money besides oil
and gas. The Russia literally went
put the flag in the Arctic Circle.
We talked to the guy who did it and said,
well we own all this.
Now we're taking all the oil and gas.
Of course,
every country that borders them as a
NATO country and if you attack one you
attack them all. So this is why the Cold
War, heating it up. People are afraid.
Any who. So we go to the Arctic
is melting. Greenland is melting.
Everyone now is like, yeah, yeah, okay
we'll give you, that will give you,
Greenland is melting in the Arctic melting
but Antarctica is actually gaining in
ice. So like it's kind of evening its
self out, which is crazy to begin with.
But we're like okay,
instead of saying you're crazy,
we're going to say okay fuck it,
we'll go,
we'll go down and we'll see what the
fuck it is. So we go down with NASA,
we go down with, you know, the top
scientists in the world from, I mean from,
from well from about
20 different countries.
But the top guy is a French
guy and we go to the,
to the South Pole and we're
like, so, so, so the, you know,
Arctic is melting and
Greenland is melting, but
Antarctica is not like we have,
we have ice gain and they're like,
you're fucking stupid. Like
what the fuck? And because what,
what was happening was their
sea ice, right? Which is like,
like if it's like a lake
freezes and then it melts,
it freezes and it melts and the lake
doesn't go up or down because it's ours.
It's the same water.
It's like an ice cube that's already
in the glass just melted. It doesn't
land ice old die. The shit that's melting.
It's like putting new ice in the glass.
Right? So it overflowed that sea
level rise. So they're like, yeah,
there's CIS gain on this side
and on this side, the sea,
the sea ice is the shit that doesn't
matter. I don't know this side land.
Ice Is fucking melting
as fast as it can go.
Land Rights is a scary shit because
land ice is the adding the new water in.
So that sea level rise. That's
glaciers. Glaciers. Exactly.
So I go down there and I go with
all these different scientists.
I go on planes with lasers and radars
to fucking measure everything and all
these dudes and scientists and everyone
like, oh fuck yeah, like, like board,
like yeah, it's a given. He has a
mounting, it's going to melt. We're done.
We're going to fucking mouth.
And we're like,
well,
why don't we know about that? And
they're like, well we do, I mean,
we published the reports, published the
data NASA published today. That's fine.
Bob Is the data. And you're like, um,
I'm a guy who does this for a living
and I don't know this shit. Like,
why the fuck? So you know, we got the
top scientists and we went to the thing,
whatever. And they're like, yeah, oh
fuck yeah, it's going to be at, you know,
three meters, four meters. And, and
at that point you're like, well,
that remaps the world. Shouldn't we be
making a bigger fucking deal about this?
Because you know, and I always get shit
for shit talking about it. I'm not,
you know me,
I'm not a tree hugger.
I'm a fucking beer drinking
football stuff and staking guy.
But when I see shit like this,
I go,
uh,
why the fuck aren't we
freaking the fuck out?
Because all the wars in the world don't
matter if we add three or four meters of
sea level rise. So don't get anything
on the ocean in Malibu. Don't do that.
That what you're saying is
that the hidden message here?
Well if you do sell it within five years,
dude's that live in those stilt houses.
Like how confident are you that the
ocean is not going to take your place?
Man Tilts into the sand.
Oh, tanker didn't cement.
That's going to stop the ocean.
The ocean anyway. How much quicker?
We don't have to get into this year's.
We're backing into doom and gloom,
but it's okay the it's
going so got some water.
Good IBCC report.
Well the one thing is is we won't,
it looks like a lot of people won't
die because they'll move, right? We,
we have legs and we can move. We can build
new cities and shit. The problem is, is,
you know, we, we, we, we go
to Antarctica and all these,
they're all scientists are all dudes
and they're like either, you know,
very clinical, I guess Robert lose three
meters and meanness and listen to this.
And then you go to Bangladesh, which is
sort of at sea level and they're just,
you know,
I think last year alone there was like
20 million climate change migrants.
So then you go to the city and it's
just, I mean it's fucking, you know,
it's just everything breaks
down. Nothing works. Just, just,
there's 20 million people in the city
that's built for 2 million people.
It's just, it's, it's just
crazy. And you're like, when
do you see it? You Go, oh,
rich people or whatever,
it will be able to move up the hill or
Colorado or whatever the fuck it is.
And everyone else is just like,
well,
you guys have to stay in the garbage
heaps and see how you, how you can do it.
And when, when, when you see it going
forward. Like, I'm a, I'm a positive guy.
I believe things you know,
genuinely have gotten better throughout
history and quality of life has gotten
better and health has gotten better and
all this shit. But you know, you're,
you're basically saying,
well,
if there's going to be
hundreds of millions of people
forced to move because of
this,
then that's going to cause chaos.
Chaos generally isn't good for anyone
who is a young 20 year old dude with a
club in his hand, you know? Yeah.
And even him, it's really not.
It's good for him for a bit. Tell
somebody with a bigger club, fuck.
Take a person who's better at hitting
what is the longest pipeline we have as
far as oil.
Like I know there's,
that's one of the issues that keystone
pipeline when you're trying to get oil
all the way from Alaska,
right? Yeah. I mean,
my question being, why can't we do that
with ice? With all the water's draining,
just pumping into cal
California needs water.
Just bring a pipeline of water down here
and just spray that stupid death valley
area. That area is stupid. Let's turn
death valley into a forest. You know,
you can. Yes, you can do that.
But that would be the shit.
But then it's the ice,
it still gets in and the
SI tables still whatever.
Just by fucking real estate in Greenland.
Right.
Cause it's kind of two people are doing
lush tropical people are actually,
well mining companies because you
couldn't get to the, to the land before.
Now that mining companies are buying it
all up because of the ice has melted.
When was it named? He was it, was it
named Greenland ironically or was it yeah,
that's a good point.
It was named that because it was Iceland
and Greenland and they switched the
names because I believe it
was Leif Ericson or Erik,
the Red Leif Erickson or one of the
reds. One of Erickson's. Anyway,
he went there and he didn't want people
cause he wanted it to be his own.
So he named Iceland, Iceland
and Greenland. Greenland
to freak them out. Okay.
So the went to Greenland looking for
what the fuck. Everything is nice.
Then he Iceland's the sweet spot.
Iceland's the sweet spot.
That is a good spot to his, if I can give
some love the documentaries on Iceland,
you guys did one on the Iceland.
Strong men fucking dude's to
just carry rocks around up there.
They're ridiculous people.
There's some crazy genetics going on.
I got to move there. I was just
going to move. They're big.
They're big motherfucker so big. They're
like freakish, like cartoon for date.
But what's weird about it is that there's
a ton of them. It's not like one dude,
one genetic anomaly could lift
the fucking car above his head.
It's like there's 17 of them that all
the strongest dudes in the world are all
from one fucking tiny little place.
They all have those crazy fucking
names too that are really difficult to
pronounce.
There's always a magnus in there
from the late, you know, there's so,
there's so much, but I guess they are.
I mean it makes sense.
They're like this descendants of vikings
and certainly they just lift shit all
day while they're just
manly. It's fun. I mean,
if you're the descendants of the,
some of the greatest conquerors in
the most part, parent conquers ever.
It's just that genetics doesn't just stop.
It's also fucking,
even if they're not in jail, like
whoever lived or whoever was like the,
the product of sex with one of those men,
like if those women lived
and their children lived,
even if the Viking didn't live,
that's like you're talking about
some insane genetics problem.
It's also not like la or, or
you know, let's say Panama,
we can pick the bananas off the trees.
Like to live in Iceland,
you gotta be tough as fuck.
You got to go out on freezing cold water
and like stab a cod. The spirit. Yeah.
Like it's, it's hard. It's,
it's cold and forbidding.
You got to learn how to drive in the
ice. Yeah. It's fun as hell though.
I love Iceland. It's a great,
but I love Greenland actually.
I went there and was blown
away by how beautiful it was.
Did you eat that shark dish that they
have that's supposed to be disgusting,
that fermented, fermented puffin? I
believe that what it is. Yeah. Yeah. No,
I did. No, I'm not into
fuck. You know, I'm not like,
my thing is to go to weird countries and,
and shoot the newsy but not eat the
shit because I get the shit to anyways.
So if I'm eating fermented puffing,
I'm like,
I'm not getting on that plane gets
a shark dish. It's maybe it's a,
I know they have,
maybe it's a pickle.
I know they have fermented puffin and
it's the most disgusting fucking thing in
the world because it comes from, it comes
from Matt, Jess or whatever it's called,
which is the fermented herring,
which they had to make illegal in
Sweden because it stank so bad.
So they made it like you can't make
it in your house or shit anymore.
You can't make it. No, it's illegal,
but it's a Swedish national did.
They can't cause it stinks so bad.
And then,
and then instead of the fermented herring,
they did the fermented Puffin,
which I dunno, well they might do that
as well, but they do do a shark thing.
It's called a hot Cari.
Okay. How Carl? I guess it's
how Carl, all right. Whatever.
I don't know how they talk. It's, it's
a very interesting pronunciation. Um,
but it's a Greenland shark.
Uh,
or other sleeper shark that's been cured
with a particular fermentation process
and hung to dry for four to five
months. It turns black. Yeah,
I've seen it hanging.
Oh my God.
Look up fermented puffin now you give
me my five minutes for minted puffin.
Fermented puffing and puffing.
Puffing is the cute, it's like a
cute looking bird, I think Icelandic.
Yeah, they apparently they ferment a lot
of shit. Yeah. They ferment a puffin.
They ferment often, which is a
bird. Yeah, a cute little bird.
And they ferment the fucker and it
reeks so bad. And then, you know,
it's one of these things where
you have to eat it or whatever.
And I used to go out to eat it. I don't
care. And then you're just, yeah, I'm not,
I'm not going to eat the fermented puffin.
I think if you live in a place like
scary as far as climate and as harsh as
Iceland, you learn how to eat fucking
everything. Puffins they just,
you know how they do what they call it?
Sky Fishing.
Apparently it says there
are hunted by sky fishing,
which involves catching low
flying birds with a big net.
So they just like calves,
nets in the sky.
They look all these bourbons that they
scoop up birds from the sky as they're
flying, ferment them until they're
rotten and then eat them. Oh,
this is so disgusting.
They bottle it and there's all sorts of
different ways they'd cook it. Uh, but uh,
it's uh,
well smoked and cured sometimes,
but the fermented one is this disgusting.
I'm not doing the fermented toughen.
The Greenland, the one that basking
shark is what I saw Bordain eat.
And uh, it looked pretty
foul. Yeah. Oh No.
We don't want to do that.
But it's, that's must be,
develop a taste for it
because you need that protein.
There's not a lot of options. I
guess. So. I mean, I smelled the,
the fermented herring. The
Swedes do. And you're like,
it's like hardcore hardcore
ammonia and you're like, how,
like it's telling you not to eat it.
Like, why would the fuck would you,
I don't know why. Yeah. I mean, what,
what happens to a person's body does that,
like they get get they're
accustomed to it. It was like a,
I have no idea. I mean that doesn't
make any sense. I have no idea.
I mean less you're starving
and Iceland gets a plane. Oh,
you have a weird thing like kids,
you know,
you develop your taste when you're kid and
like, you know what Natto is, you know?
No, it's like fermented
beans. Very strong taste.
Everyone in Japan eats it for breakfast,
not too, oh, delicious. Not the end.
It's like,
it's like from like rotten,
rotten sticky beans and
it's, but you know, again,
you go there and they love it and they
eat it with a sort of strong mustard.
But um, you got a lot of
places. I remember, you know,
I was sick somewhere
anyway. He was somewhere, uh,
maybe it was Katmandu. Anyways,
I was sick and they brought
me the spiciest like
craziest fucking Chili, like,
you know, Vindaloo and,
and I was like, I'm sick.
I want like a grilled cheese sandwich and
ginger rail. Like, you know, I want to,
and they brought me the spiciest crazy
chili shit and it, it's just, look,
everybody has a different, I
don't know, different, you know,
comfort food or whatever when they're
sick or whatever they believe they're
going to eat or something.
Well,
they say that fermentation is how people
figured out how to make alcohol. Yeah.
We'll figure it out. They got drunk
from fermented things. Do you get,
is there a certain amount of intoxication
you get from those? From Amy maybe?
I Dunno, that's a good question. I know
alcohol, it was a way to transport water.
Wine was a way to transport
water. They're like, oh,
because a lot of places they would go to,
it was a big thing.
Anthrax was huge because the,
the animals would go to know and they
fall in the water and then the whole pond
or the whole water source
becomes an [inaudible].
That's where anthrax
comes from. Yeah. Yeah.
So it just comes from like
a decaying animal. Yeah.
And so and so it was a lot
of water was unsafe. So like,
oh we need to figure out a
way to carry water with us.
And they figured out a lot of ways,
but wine was one of them.
One or we can carry this for you know,
years we can get of this.
And they didn't have corks that just
put a bit of olive oil on top of it,
which would seal it.
And I was like,
that means that if you go logically,
they were drinking a shit pile
of wine because they were like,
well I'm not going to trust the water
cause I don't know that the animals
haven't died in it, so I'll just drink
wine all day every day. I lived off wine.
That is hilarious.
What explains like a lot of the crazy
shit that people can get it back then just
drunk in bands of marauders going
up from hillside the hillside. Yeah.
That's really crazy.
If you stop and think about it,
like the people that were traveling
and drinking wine and exclusively for
hydration,
what the difference it must've been
on the way they thought and behaved.
Explains a lot of history.
It does. We're really fair.
We're figuring it all out here. Yes. We
figured out two things. I figure it out.
We just got to get a pipeline. I'm
black man from Antarctica or Greenland,
pour that water in the palm springs
and palm desert, all that area.
Just fucking make it a lush, lush
tropical forests. We could do that.
All right. Just how about a big pipe
and like a sprinkler system over la?
It just rains while La la needs water
magic. That's what it came down to.
We have artificial eggland high rail,
uh,
like shower systems over cities.
There's a rain anymore in la.
So La decided it needed a shower system.
We'd cause a lot of,
a lot of news saying we're going to
reuse the keystone pipeline, not for oil,
but for glaciers so that we can actually
have water. That would be bad ass.
Nobody would oppose that
pose. Moving water. Well,
if oil keeps going down
and water keeps going up,
it will be economically feasible.
You make more money selling water,
then you will be a commodity. Yeah. Yeah.
That's the, that's the projection, right?
We're,
we're going to actually have an issue
with fresh water but then the next 50 to
60 years or we have an issue with it now.
What will you see those lakes, Texas,
if you've been to Austin, Have Lake
Travis and Lake Austin and Lake Travis.
They don't artificially feet like
Austin looks bad ass but lake Travis has
vanished all the uh, yeah, we
did a piece on it. All the,
the houseboats and everything are
sitting just on like not even dry land.
Like cake, like scorched land. Yeah.
And the docs are nowhere near the water
anymore. I don't know. Hundreds of yards.
It's a weird,
it's like you will Texas but has
been in drought now for three years.
Three years as this California. Yeah. I
think there there's this worse is worse.
Also they have a lot of
agriculture there too, right?
They have a lot of agriculture
farm. The big thing is now the, the,
I believe the numbers are staggering.
Like one third of of beef cattle are
gone. Like, you know, like just trip,
which in Texas is a huge numbers,
millions and millions and we have
a lot of agriculture in California,
but we have nearly as much
as Texas has. I think, uh,
like Louise more water.
Well I think there's more straight
up ag agriculture in California,
but there's more uh, like
to, and Shit, you know,
there's this many tigers in
Texas is there are in the wild.
That's tragic and weird. It's
amazing. But there's, yeah,
I mean there's not that many left in the
wild and there's a lot of crazy people
in Texas. They want to buy
one. So it doesn't surprise me.
Texas has a huge population
of these wildlife parks.
They had a wild game parks where you
could go like shoot a zebra. Yeah.
With a compound bow go hunters,
zebra.
Like they have these crazy fucking
parks where they have wild animals.
It's not just a few. There's a lot
of people have private collections.
I've heard of that. And my favorite
story is not actually in Texas, but uh,
in, in Columbia where a
Escobar loved wild animals.
So he bought like hippos
and elephants and tigers.
And then when it all went to shit,
they just went into the jungle and
they're just procreating and living and
you're like, it's kind of, that's
kind of cool actually, you know? Yeah.
Probably environmentally. They're not
supposed to have elephants and in,
in Columbia. But uh, having the, the,
the animals sort of set free into the wild
is I think, I think it was good. Yeah.
Well there's,
um,
there's a lot of people in this
country that have private collections.
They have one animals. There was the guy
that lived in Ohio. He opened his gates,
let all of his animals out, and then blew
his brains out. No cops, cops showed up.
And you know,
there's all these wild animals,
including is dangerous
ones like lions and shit.
So these cops have to shoot these animals.
They can't even save him because he
can't let them go out into the wild,
not wild cities, suburban
neighborhood. It's close.
So then I just
wind up shooting all of them. But
it's, this guy was fucking crazy.
But you can just do that.
You can have tigers in your yard.
Like Mike Tyson had a tiger.
Like you can have a tiger.
Like that is insane. Like there
needs to be a law on that. Like that,
that's more ridiculous than guns.
No more tigers left in the world.
But you know,
Joe blow down in Dallas comes
inside like a tiger, send me,
listen son. I got the healthiest tag
or community and all of North America,
he's here. Tigers. These are direct
from India. I don't fuck with them.
Siberian tigers. There's
slower. Okay. They're lazy.
They don't kill. Yeah. There's a,
there's a ton of wild game
parks in Texas where they,
they took a lot of animals that were
almost extinct in Asia and now they're
thriving. And today's,
yeah. Species of deer.
Like there's many species of deer that
they have that they take from other
countries. Uh, and they bring to America
and they put them in his game parks,
especially in Texas. And then they can
hunt them anytime they want. Right, right.
Because they become like a
commodity instead of it being like,
there's seasons for deer
and the season for it.
There's seasons for everything else,
but these animals that are non
[inaudible] non native, yeah.
Get on them anytime you want.
So they bring them over there just
specifically for that purpose,
but so they're thriving because they're
worth something. Right, right, right.
She's really kind of trippy
know. It's like, yeah,
you want the animals to be thriving.
But it's kind of weird that the only way
they're thriving is if dudes to get out
there and shoot.
But
this is, you know, not a, uh,
a tremendously popular, uh,
um, sort of argument, but it
actually makes a lot of sense.
Like when we did this piece
on, um, a rhino poaching,
you know,
they,
they killed the rhino just for the horn
because they sell it in Vietnam as an
aphrodisiac.
And the guy who is trying to
save the rhinos is saying,
you know, legalize it and we'll take the
horns off. Cause you can take the whole,
it's like, it's made it like,
it's like to hair. Yeah.
You can take the horn off and we'll just
sell it and then therefore they don't
have to kill the rhinos for the horn.
It'll just be a market and everyone's
freaking out saying, no, no, no, but,
but as long as dudes who are poor can
make a ton of money for killing thing to
take the horn, they will. Whereas if
you just say, okay, well, you know,
we'll give you the fucking horn and you
can do whatever they want you to have as
many voters as you want,
go nuts.
That's the only way to save them
is capitalism is killing them.
So capitalism has to save them.
And initially you go,
well that doesn't sound right,
but when you think about
it, you're like, well, okay.
Yeah. Then the problem is,
well somebody will be like,
someone will regulate
it and like a company,
GM will make the money out
of the illegal rhino horns,
but they'll still be illegal
rhino horns because the,
the guys will get disenfranchising.
They'll get screwed out
of it somehow.
But in any way,
the argument that you have to make it
as economically viable to do the thing
because otherwise they'll
just kill to get killed out.
[inaudible] massive rhino horns really
did give you a hard on rhinos would have
been extinct a long fucking time
ago for it to really work. Well,
the other thing is,
is like you're like rhino horns give
you a hard on and whatever. You're like,
just fucking buy Viagra.
Cialis 99 cents is a lot
cheaper because it's expensive.
It's like 20 grand for a piece
of rhino and you're like,
you get fucking a vat of Viagra for that.
You could bathe in Viagra.
The rest of it all day, every
day. Like, what the fuck?
It's 20 grand. So expensive. It's crazy.
But it doesn't do anything. It's just
like eating someone's hair. Yeah. I mean,
similar. I'm going to grind a fingernail
and I'm going to grind up the hair and
fingernails and uh, and
that's gonna get me hard. But,
but, but seriously,
like just take fucking,
they bootleg Viagra for like a penny,
you know what I mean? Anyway. Well,
they also put it in those a boner pills
that you buy at gas stations. Like they,
those boner pills that you put
Viagra, they put the Rhino Horn. No,
they put via those,
those boner pills itself for like three
95 for like a little packet. You know,
I don't want to go try him. I don't
know. I don't know those ones.
Ben Takes Him all the time. That's a
fucking freak. He's always buying them.
And I'm like,
why won't you just buy real Viagara
we know what the fuck you're taking.
Taking this crazy shit
from this gas station.
You know what's called red hot super
deck, you know, but a gel. I got two back,
just red hot super deck. What's it?
Um, I don't know, but the shit works.
That's no worst. That's no better than
eating Rhino Horn. That's just, well,
it's no better than eating
garbage you find on the street.
But we did another piece on that that I
found fascinating because I didn't know
anything about it, was that,
you know, you have a, you know,
like first of all bath salts,
you know,
people were like fucking and then
eating each other and like I fucking,
while they eat them and I'm
like, what, what are they
doing? How do they have bath?
Like bath salts? And they're like, what's
not, they're not fucking bath salts.
He called them bath salts,
but you can buy them in the corner store
and now they have like their legal,
you know, they have fake cannabinoids
or they have fake, uh, uh,
whatever other kinds of chemicals
or get you high, whatever.
And what happened was in New Zealand,
um,
math was such a huge problem that they,
that they went to the government and said,
let's make like a healthier
version of math or you know, seed.
But like with, just with chem,
like real chemicals and stuff.
And so they did, they illegally
made, you know, drugs,
pills and the math problem went down.
And you know,
they were healthier version
of drugs or whatever,
but they were like selling them next to
like chocolate bars and shit. So the, the,
the, you know, the moms and
everybody went, well, this is not
cool that you can buy math next to the
chocolate bars. Quite rightly. And,
and they,
so they banned them again.
But what happened was online you can go
and just change the molecule and before
the DEA, you know, get catch
up. You just change it again.
And in China they have these companies
where you can just email them saying d to
the power of seven. And they're like,
right, I'll send you 10 kilos tomorrow.
So it comes in,
they just mix it up,
put it in a package of Scooby doo
and the cover and say, there you go.
And you can sell them legally until
you have to change the molecule again.
And there's like the, the, you know, you,
you, you smoke these things, his snoring,
me do whatever and they're fucking
so strong, like crazy strong.
And, and here's me mister hipster going,
I didn't even know that fucking existed.
You can walk into any corner store
and buy these off the rack and just go
outside into the back and,
and go to Neptune.
And have they,
they've made it illegal
in a few different states.
But the problem is they
have to specify what exactly
go it and they just alter a thing.
And then there's a new wave and then
they alter a thing and then there's,
and bath salts was, uh, somebody
put the wrong molecule in there.
And we decided that we were getting eat,
somebody knows off as we were having
sex and that was one of the side effects
might experience sexual addiction
and cannibalism simultaneously.
My favorite drug reaction ever was there.
There's a drug called
reequip and re equipped.
They were given to people that suffer
from Parkinson's degree. Oh Shit.
Parkinson's syndrome. And
uh, they gave it to this guy,
I think it was in Dublin and it turned
him into a gay sex and junkie and a
gambling junkie.
The guy all of a sudden became
gay from this Parkinson's disease,
started having risky gay sex with a man,
like leaving ads to meet, meet up places,
meeting guys and having sex with him.
Had no idea we were in gambling,
couldn't stop gambling.
Like it was just completely
addicted to gambling all day long.
You just wanted to gamble
and won in court. The,
the American equivalent of
somewhere around $600,000
really proved that it was just him going,
fuck it.
I gotta get out of jail free card. I'm
going for the full blue bull goose loony.
I'm buckets it seems like. Right? Yeah.
I've always wanted just fucking random.
I'm taking a weird pill. Get
out of jail free. Here we go.
Let my freak flag fly. Yeah. I wonder
like how much do you have to prove? Yeah,
when a case like that because it
was against Glaxo Smith Kline.
Yeah, you got it. A big pharmacy,
you've got to think he had a pretty,
a pretty good case cause
they would shut him down.
It has to be locked down tight.
He could never,
you can never have ever played cards or
looked at a dick before and then all of
a sudden it was just like boom. He was
living in a different country though.
They might have different
standards as far as like
what they think, you know, pharmaceutical
drug companies responsible for,
well it's Ireland, so
there's really, yeah,
I'm pretty sure it was Ireland for a few
Bob. Yeah. What a crazy story though.
You never imagined being a normal guy.
All of a sudden you just can't stop
fucking playing cards at gay orgies.
Just like,
it's just all day.
Your life is consumed with
Dick dice and just woo,
come on. Give me that.
Just a constant chaos of,
of, you know, you should
be in sales. Um, you know,
that just sounds like a good time.
Uh,
reequip case x trial. We'll find
out where the fuck this was. Yeah.
Yeah. The guy was a gifted, it's
on ABC News, man. Wow. Yeah.
Uh, Parkington medication made him a
gibbet addicted to gambling and gay sex.
Jesus. Oh my God. It's hilarious.
He was from France. So the whole
stories now suspect. I'm so sorry.
I brought this up to you folks. For sure.
That guy was just making it up. Yeah.
Fucked up. What's happening in France
right now. Yeah. That's a second.
Somehow fucked up. Yeah. Well,
we went from funny to, yeah,
we talked when we went dark.
You know what's really not funny?
I've actually seen people that are taking
this very interesting stance on this
story. Um, the whole story,
if you don't know what it is,
how do you say the name of the paper?
Charlie. Charlie Hebdo Abdo. Um,
they made the satire cartoons
about Mohammed and about Islam and,
uh, they were murdered. 10
people, two police officers,
12 people were murdered by
these, uh, Islamic hit people.
And there's been all these protests
and France and all these marches and
everybody's freaking out worldwide.
But I've seen some people take the stance
that those cartoons were offensive and
they, they were punching down
at that. That was sad to her.
They were punching down and that those,
those cartoons were racist. And that,
you know, don't they understand
that it's offensive. I read this,
a tweet actually don't they understand
that it's offensive not just to Muslims
but to one quarter of
the people on the planet.
That was what they wrote
as if that in any way,
like when do we put our foot
down and say, look, you're,
I know you're a tolerant person.
Whoever's saying this is that
you're trying to preach tolerance.
You're talking about tolerance
for something that kills people,
that draw tunes,
like look,
Charlie Hebdo and,
and cartoons and humor in general is
meant to be a mirror onto ourselves.
And you know, we take ourselves
so seriously. And when you start,
I believe if you start any type
of censorship, you're fucked.
Because when you know somebody won't
like something and then the other person
won't like the thing that you like.
And once you start down that path
and you say, well, you know Joe,
you know, uh, I hate that you know that
you like, you know, Palestine. Well Shane,
I hate to, you're like Israel.
Whatever it is, someone's always,
always going to have.
And the minute someone gets that,
then censorship starts in the minute
censorship starts. It never stops.
First of all, censorship by
fear. And we were just, you know,
we started the whole conversation about
this censorship by fear was Nazi Germany,
censorship by fear with Stalinists Russia.
Censorship by fear was mad.
I was China. And if you wrote or thought
or said anything against the state,
you got killed.
And now what we're saying is if you
do or say or do anything against a
perceived, you know, thing
about a religion, then
they're going to come get you.
Right? And people were
like, terrified, oh my God,
we're not going to show the
cartoons. We're not going
to show, we're not going to,
what do you think you can like that?
There's that many terrorists out there,
they're going to kill everybody
who retweets a fucking cartoon.
And that's the insidiousness
of, of, of, of,
of terrorism. Because then you're
like, if you make fun of anything,
if you make fun of any political leader
or political group or terrorist group or
anyone with a gun, they get can,
can of, can come out and shoot you.
And I think that's the whole
thing of like, uh, no, they're
allowed to fucking say,
guess what? You're allowed to
say whatever the fuck you want.
And then I'm allowed to say whatever
the fuck I want against you.
But the minute you say you're not allowed
to say what you want and if you do,
I'll shoot you,
then you can fuck off.
And that's what World
War II was fought over.
That's what world war one was fought over.
And if we don't say there
can be no censorship than
we should have just given up
and said, yeah, fuck,
we'll just write whatever Hitler
wants us to write because that's what
censorship is.
I was just shocked at how many people
who call themselves progressives were
taking the stance that the,
the jokes actually were inflammatory,
but they had the same fucking
jokes about everybody.
They there were an equal
opportunity asshole.
They fucking went after everybody and
that was their job. That's their thing.
They would, that it's satire.
It's making fun of Shit.
We roast for the world, a roast for
the world, but they roasted everybody.
And so the fact is you're now,
you're allowed to rose to everyone except
for these guys because these guys have,
we'll shoot you. Well, not,
it's not just dad, it's the,
what's freaking me out is not that just
that people are willing to shoot you
over cartoon. That's been
freaking me out for a long time.
But that somehow or another people that
call themselves progressive will stand
up and say, well, you know, I looked
at what these people were doing.
What they were doing was really offensive.
Like that's fucking crazy.
But you know the reason why that's
happening, why is it because
what's happening now is we're
reaching a critical mass,
right? You're reaching a
point where, which by the
way, if you look at terrorism,
it's been incredibly successful
because you're reading a quote,
you're reaching a critical mass where
worst people are saying now it will be
like this. You know, for example,
the, the fight, the, the,
the reaction always. Well, Islam
as a religion of peace. Now that's become
a joke because everyone's like, well,
it's a fucking religion of peace. Why
does this continue happening? Right?
And so progressive's or
whatever are trying to say, hey,
well maybe because they realize that
the logical conclusion of this right is
going to be, there's going to
be bad. It's going to be okay.
There is going to be an effective as
this polarized is Islamic fundamentalism
gets bigger.
And then our reaction to that fundamental
fundamentalism gets worse because,
look, I'm, I believe I'm
oppressive, progressive guy.
I don't know what that means,
but I'm nonpolitical on either side and
I believe I look at things critically.
But at a certain point you're like,
well this is getting bad now and public
opinion is getting heated and the end
result of that is going to be,
you're going to have heated
public opinion on one side,
a bunch of guys with a bunch of guns on
the other and it's not going to end well.
So people, it's a type of
appeasement, right? It's a
type of, well I looked at it,
it's not so bad.
Well it is bad,
but that is high in terms of
excitement by progressive's, um,
by really liberal people,
which uh,
the same type of people that will
shit on Christians but use the term
Islamophobic for any criticism
of an Nad. Jokes. In fact,
any jokes in fact about Islam or
Muslims can be seen as Islamophobic,
but the same type of people that would
have no problem shitting your Christian
Jews. And it's just weird thing. It's
because of this, this is what become,
what's the park? It's appeasement.
And, and quite frankly,
what's good for the goose is good for the
gander. Everybody should be game. And,
and that's what freedom is all about.
Who's it appeasement to?
It's this weird social brownie point
thing that they're doing where they're,
they're maybe looking at
it as an opportunity to
criticize racism or criticize,
punching down with humor. You
know, maybe I, I mean, I, sorry,
I'm getting a drink. So, no worries man.
I think, you know, for me, I think it's,
it's,
we're afraid of the outcome because
if we keep going on this trajectory,
the outcome is going to be problematic.
I think you have a point there for sure.
But I also think one of the things that's
going on is there's a bunch of people
in this culture that have this bizarrely
Utopian version of what they would like
us to be like the way we
should react to anything.
People that think that they're a Fox
something, someone that, uh, decides to,
uh, have whatever, any strange
idea they may have in their head.
We're supposed to be as even
keeled with them as possible. Well,
I don't want to get started on politics.
I think politics in this country
is fucked. I think it's Moreso,
I think it's fucked
and it's getting worse.
And we could go on till the cows come
home about politics in this country.
Um, one thing I would like
if we were, if you want,
I would be long winded and boring for
most people, but, um, I read a book,
if anyone wants to read maybe the most
fascinating book ever written about the,
uh, the, uh,
the situation that we're dealing with
right now and with the rest of the world.
And Islam is a,
is called the siege of Maca.
And it's a true story. It's a
journalist who wrote it about in 1979,
which was the, the, the difference, uh,
I believe the year 1400
in the Islamic calendar,
there was a siege of Maca and,
uh,
a bunch of dudes who were wahabiists
took over Maca during Hajj and the Royal
Government,
uh,
the royal family couldn't go get them
because it's illegal to fight in Mecca.
And so there was a standoff and there
were fighting people shooting each other
and snipers.
It's like an action movie.
The French secret service gave them
drugs to drug them. And, and uh,
at the time it was the same time that
that was happening. Uh, the, the,
the hostage crisis in Toronto, the
ayatollah was a smart dude goes, yeah,
the Americans,
the CIA have taken over Mecca,
which of course is like the worst
thing you could possibly fucking do.
So there's this whole upper, early,
they burnt the embassy in Pakistan.
They do all these things
because everyone's like,
fuck the CIA have taken over Maca,
you know,
and what ended up happening as long
story but incredible action movie story.
But what happened was the royal family
had to go to the clerics and say,
you've got to give us a fat whether
we can go into Mecca and fight,
because you're literally not allowed
to bring a gun in a sword. Nothing.
And so you have to give us a special
fatwa to go get these terrorists.
And they're like, well, we kind of believe
in what they're saying because the,
the, the terrorist, we're actually,
you're just a hobbyist saying
we need to be more wahabiists,
which is fundamental Islam.
So they said,
we'll give you the fatwah if you then
basically give us money to do what they're
asking for it to, to be well
hobbyist. So then anyways, it happens,
they go to kill the guys
guy named Jude Haman.
But then what happens is from then on,
billions and billions of petro dollars,
which we pay the Saudi government
then goes to the Ulama,
the clerics who then send
that money to every country,
America, UK, France, you know,
Pakistan.
And they build the biggest mosques.
And because Maca is like the Vatican
would be in the UL mark or like the pope,
they built the biggest mosques and they,
you know,
spend the most money and then they
say, okay, now you teach Wahhabi Islam.
And you know, when you look at
what's happening with Isis, you say,
how the fuck can these guys
recruit 50,000 foreign fighters in,
in four fucking months? It doesn't make
any sense. They're coming from America,
they're coming from France or coming from
England because these guys go to these
mosques where there were
hobbyists teachings, right?
And then when you look at it,
and when you look at what's happening
with things happening in France with
things happening in the UK with
things happening in Pakistan,
w w where we're saying we're not
going to go with the Taliban,
even in Pakistan now where we're going
with isis or the Taliban is aligning with
Isis and you say,
how the fuck can that happen overnight?
How can it happen that all these people
are saying, fuck yeah, that's great. Isis.
It's because we have the pope and
the Vatican saying that that's good.
That will hobby ism as good.
So as long as that continues,
the problem on the, that side
is going to get worse. Right?
And then as long as
that problem gets worse,
we're going to fucking react stronger
and stronger as is only human.
And that's the problem is, is we're
heading for some sort of boiling over,
we're heading for some sort of,
you know, thing. And I think,
and this is me giving people
the benefit of the doubt,
is that some people are
saying, well fuck if, if,
if we just let into everything now and
say, you know, everyone's shooting us.
If we say the wrong
thing, fuck you, let's go.
Then it's going to happen sooner
rather than later. Which, which,
which might be inevitable
if Maca keeps on funding.
Wahabiists Sunni doctrine.
Jesus fucking in Christ Shane.
Goddamn doom and gloom.
Sorry Bitch.
The world is melting coming from Russia.
It's coming from,
maybe North Korea is going to kidnap
your wife and forced her to do porn. No,
God dammit. This is all this shit. Sorry.
Right now let's start
15 with some positivity.
God Damn you freaking me the fuck that.
Start with the positive. What about the,
wow, the thing is we can change
it all. We're human beings.
We're smart and I believe there's enough
of us now that are woken up and are
smart and understand our political and
economic power and we could stop all this
shit from happening.
Cause I'll tell you what,
North Korea only exists because
people let it exist. Right.
Global warming only continues
because we let it continue.
I mean fucking other problems that we
have with terrorism only continue because
we let it fucking continue.
If humanity as a whole says we ain't
going to fucking do that anymore,
it would stop tomorrow.
We would need a lot of people to band
together to go after North Korea though.
North Korea seems like a huge problem.
And on top of that,
don't think I have like nuclear weapons.
I mean how are you going to stop?
Well stop it from inside.
You have to stop it from inside.
But I think that that's where like
everyone running around freaking out about
the interview. Oh my God, North Korea
fucking told us we can't do something.
We should be figuring out ways of
getting the interview into North Korea.
We should in fact fuck the interview.
We should be figuring out how to get
at an NFL football into North Korea or,
or like fucking, you
know, lassie or Heidi,
your dukes of hazard or any kind
of shit. Because I think, you know,
one of the smartest things that America
learned after World War One and World
War Two is if you, your troops
had costs a lot of fucking money,
and it takes a lot of lives where if
you figure out that Marlboro's cokes and
Mcdonald's and Hollywood, uh,
everybody loves them, then guess what?
You don't have to fight the war.
You want. Everybody's like, fucking,
I want to smoke.
This is Barbara while I'm drinking a
coke and watch and Brad Pitt, you know,
Graham ski and hedge money.
And I think that we should be exporting
our culture a lot more aggressively in
the North Korea. And I'll tell you what,
Kim Jong Un grew up in Switzerland.
He loves basketball.
He was watching TV.
He knows what fucking time and he's
in the, he's watched the, you know,
fucking Dukes of Hazzard. He or I
guess you'd be later. He'd be, what?
What's the big 90 show?
Check it out.
I'm using the Detroit Pistons,
right? Isn't he a big fan of, uh,
what's his face? Rodman. Well,
he was, yeah, he was bulls.
They liked the bulls cause it was Jordan.
Right. But what else did he play for it?
Did he pay for the play Pistons and then
they pistol's distance and bowls? Yeah,
you're right. He's got like metal
all over his face now. Yeah.
What's going on with that dude?
He's a weird dude.
He's always been a weird guy that Kim
Jong Uhmm is sort of connected to.
We sent them there. You know that?
Yeah. But how the fuck is that real?
Because they love fucking the bowls.
I mean,
if Michael Jordan would have gone
there and I hope Michael Jordan,
he listened to this.
If Michael Jordan would have gone there,
it would have been world peace. I mean
forced him to do ebony porn. You know,
I think, I think there would have been
so much good will. He was said, look,
let's just fucking call it a day.
Do you think so if Michael Jordan,
he would have been and he would,
I think he would have been a god like
ambassador and he would have been a little
bit more sane.
Really?
So you think you could have actually
gotten like diplomacy accomplished? Well,
I think there was the diplomacy
accomplished. I think if
you look at it, you know,
one of the things that, um,
well besides oil tanking, uh,
that that helped detente between Cuba and,
and America was baseball.
If you look at [inaudible] and all
the stars that came out of, of Cuba,
you know, the culturally, they were
just like, okay, fuck it. Fuck this.
Let's just do it. And
I think that, you know,
the number one sport in
North Korea is basketball.
And so it's like if Jordan had gone there,
or even if the bowls would've gone there
and there had been a real fucking thing
and a cultural outreach or whatever, it
would have at least sped it up, right?
Because that was ping pong
diplomacy. They were like, wow,
we don't actually eat each other's babies.
We play fucking Ping Pong.
Like he like, like staying like w you
know, everybody's kind of, you know,
when I went,
I was always,
I grew up at the end of the Cold War
and I was fascinated by propaganda.
I was fascinated by
eastern Europe and when I,
as soon as it opened up and went to
Prague and progress was inundated with
Americans. So then I went to
Budapest and then I went to Kia.
But it was like not that much
fucking different. They had,
they had a car and they an apartment,
they got two weeks and
they went to lake bow tie.
It was a shitty car and it was a sheet,
but no fucking guy from
point a to point B.
And they kind of were pissed off at their
government, but they were kind of like,
wow,
whatever, fuck there's food
in the second story, you know?
And it was kind of shitty year.
It was a shitty or gray or w you know,
scary or I guess cause
of the police version.
But in reality it's like people are
fucking people at the end of the day,
except for North Korea. I mean North
Korea, it's just fucking crazy.
But I think that the more,
it's not actually us, we're
not doing shit over there.
At least they think where the devil.
But Chinese people who used to come look,
they were wearing the man with suit and
with the stars everywhere and they look
the same and they talked to Sam and there
was still revolutionary are now coming
in Hawaiian shirts and with a cannon
fucking ass five and a fucking thing.
It's our culture got over there.
Yeah.
I think global culture got
there and consumers culture,
I mean China is the most capitalist
country in the world now,
but the Chinese who are coming in North
Korea don't look like them any more.
They don't act like that.
I mean they have fucking laser
beams in their hands like phones,
they don't have phones,
they don't have computers.
So they see all this shit from the Chinese
and go, oh okay, something's going on.
And I think if we, if we just exported
our culture that the fact that hey guys,
you're actually living in
fucking a hundred years ago,
you should come and get
up to speed with us.
I mean that's what happened in East
Germany, east Germany, Western.
And they said this is never
going to come together. Boom.
They realize that these motherfuckers
over there and driving nine eleven's and
I'm driving a fucking louder.
So you know, that's what one,
that's one won the war. This
is there a way though. Did
anybody could ever, I mean,
you'd have to get rid of
that whole family. You'd have
to get rid of that whole,
I dunno. I mean government that's
running. I mean, it's just soften.
The family does, I mean, now who the fuck
knows? I don't know shit. But you know,
from what I know about going there a lot,
the military runs everything.
It's called military first.
The army runs everything.
Whenever the army runs
everything anywhere, guess
what? It's not a ton of fun.
Kim Jong Moon is, is uh, is, is he looks
like his, his, his Granddad, you know,
he's a dad. He, they got him out
of power. They killed number two.
They fucked with his wife. They did all
this shit, always got gout. They go away.
They were just saying saying,
hey, you know who's running shit?
The army's running shit because if the
army isn't running shit in North Korea,
it's over. Because the minute
the army isn't running shit,
they're going to all be in line saying,
can I please work at high die for some
money cause I'm fucking hungry. Yeah,
that's so true. It'll be exactly
what happened in East Germany.
I got a great idea for a buddy comedy.
How about this? How about Kim
John Own captures a basketball,
a college basketball
team from like whatever,
like the World Championship
College Basketball is
whatever the Flint talky get's
Kentucky. Yeah, whatever the big,
the big team is, captures them.
Reroutes their plane.
It lands in North Korea and kidnaps him
and forces them to play basketball for
him and they wind up taking on the North
Korean army kicking everybody's ass and
taking over the country and they
become the president of North Korea.
I like it except for,
except for,
I'd like to change it to
the best college basketball
team in America gets kidnapped
by the North Korean, uh,
desk spot,
which makes them play the worst pro team
in America for a winner take all game
because it's always that
question at the end of the year,
if the best college team plays
the worst pro team who would win.
And I love those arguments and
everyone's always like, well,
if Oakland played Bama Wall,
now it's a buckeyes.
But if let's say Bama, cause
I love Bam, if, if Oakland
played Bammo, then you know,
they would throw so many schemes up
against them and they couldn't have,
but you're like, Bam, I had the
biggest offensive line in football,
not only not just fucking, uh,
college football, football.
And they played together as a team and
they're fucking Austin now. They sucked,
you know, against Ohio. But in
any case, the best college team,
because then you could bet on it,
you could bet on it.
And whoever won between American
North Korea would run the world.
I think we should do that.
That's what we should set up.
What if they want North Korea?
We're on block,
then we'll have to kick their ass again.
We wanted the world for a second.
We're fucked.
We're not going to let you won the
world forever for a basketball game.
What do you retarded then we've failed
in our mission, but the pros should,
should win the Dream Team.
Dream Team sharing happens in sports.
You remember the Dream Team?
People get tweaked and Spain. Yes.
Michael Jordan wasn't there
like a hockey game to where?
Well that was the opposite Americans.
That was the opposite.
That was the Russians were effectively
pros because they were the restaurant and
they would go and then we were still
putting up college players and even though
the Russians were pros and
we're going to kill us, we won.
So we became the underdog. We
were, we were. We champion. Yeah.
We also take day for the hockey people.
It is a huge day to beat those
ruskies have to beat the rush.
The Cold War was played.
We Ha we need to cut kind of cold
war again just to have sports. Well,
you know what? Fighting Sports, fighting.
We've learned a lot from Russians.
I'll tell you that.
We've learned a lot how God damn tough.
They are tough motherfucker.
When we compare the softness
of the average American male,
so that shit I see on TV,
the Russians do the crazy,
the military guys over in
Russia or are mean as fuck.
Oh yeah, for sure. It's
not just a military guys,
but I mean just the average humans in
Russia. But we'll just send drones,
we'll send laser computer people
over there while we won't win,
we won't win if we fight the, well you've
seen the shit. They fucking have to,
you know,
squatting or haunches for three days
and what can kicked in the face.
I mean they're in a
different level of shit now.
Not to take anything away from
the best military in the world,
which is the American military. But the
Russians are fucking tough motherfucker.
You hit him in the face with a baseball
bat and they smile. So it seems like,
like whenever you hear about a crazy
concept like an MMA concept comes out of
Russia,
like that team fighting where they had
like five on five or six on six or some
shit and then
there was another one that I saw there.
There was two on two and once I,
one I saw was these guys met in like a
park somewhere and these rival teams and
they beat the shit out of each other and
a park. They just both met for a gang.
Basically. They just want to fight
the fuck out of it all the time.
If you see the Russian,
especially like the the, the,
the special service training shit
that they have to go through,
it's fucking ridiculous.
Obviously it's hard to become a seal
or a ranger or whatever, but like,
like I don't know, something like
50% of them die like some crazy stat.
They're fucking crazy. Anyway,
we don't want to fight them.
I guess why everyone who's fought them
from the Boli and they hit their devry
last set, the mangoes, mangoes,
tomorrow's memorial was beating everybody.
Mongols took over,
rushed for 200 years.
The only reason why they didn't
get the Europe is cause they got it
tired if they were all drunk,
drunk
or horses aren't big enough. My question
was, I wonder if like, because the,
because Russia has suffered the defeat
and the Cold War and economic disparity
and it was called hard times.
They've gone through some brutal
infighting and all the shit that happened,
the people that did survive
there, there, there are different,
there's like a different lineage where
they're tough as hell. Yeah. Yeah.
And I wonder if that's just what happens
and then those people rise up and then
the people like us that
are on top of things,
we start criticizing cartoons
and they get soft and fat.
And when they made the cartoon shouldn't
be punching down. Yeah. Let me get,
we get goofy. That's true. Yeah.
And then we get so unrealistic as to the
nature of man and the ways of the world
and the way things work right now.
Not a utopian vision of what
could certainly be possible.
But the fact like I saw a t shirt,
uh,
you don't like cops next time you get
in trouble, call crackhead. Well listen,
people that are complaining
and bitching about cops,
I guarantee you if someone was
breaking into your fucking house,
you're going to call nine one one right?
Whenever you're right.
But whenever I go to any of these places
and you see dude's like sleeping in the
sand, eating dirt, you know,
cuddling their coalition to cough for
warmth. And then you look at, look,
I'll be the first to put my hand up.
You're looking at me and I'm like, well,
well I have in and out
burger or a Wendy's, I will,
I have the supersized coke or the value
of them, you know, and I'm just like,
you know, I used to, when I was young,
I used to think that was a tough guy.
And when you see these dudes who literally
know nothing but an AK 47 and we'll
eat sand, you're like, yeah, I don't
want to fight that guy. And by the way,
the majority of people I
know in our country, why?
Because our country is great.
You don't want to fight
these motherfuckers cause
they w they are fucking bad
ass and it's like,
you know,
I think we've had this discussion before
but you know when you look at boxing
and shit, the tougher the neighborhood,
the poor, the neighborhood,
the better the boxer.
Cause they're fighting for something,
they want to get the fuck out.
You don't see a lot
of Harvard boxers. They're going one,
two, three current, you know dad.
And it's also, they're used to dealing
with violence on a regular basis.
They can operate more effectively
in those high pressure scenarios.
I think that's what we're
saying about Russians to these,
these are harder people.
They're,
they're stronger in will and in character
because of what they've had to go
through.
I think if you look at the last,
the two longest wars in American history,
if you look at Iraq and Afghanistan,
and then I remember when
Russia invaded Crimea,
which is 90% Russian,
you know,
Fox News was saying it was the first
time they've ever gone without a shot and
we should go in and where are we
going to do? And then you're like,
hold on a second, hold on a second.
You're talking about going into Russia,
which is Russian to fight Russians
about taking over a part of Russia.
You know, the tr traditionally
was a part of Russia. You know,
we had a hard time in Iraq with not
the greatest in the world with a lot of
terrorists. We had a hard time in, in,
in Afghanistan with the Taliban
who aren't even in an army.
And in any real sense of the word,
you're going to go take on the
Russians and Russia's backyard.
You're going to get a fucking bloody nose
like you have never experienced before.
If you're going to do it, you better be
ready to go all in. And that's, you know,
one of the things that NATO has a thing
that if you attack any NATO country,
all of NATO then has to go and go with
you obviously were a part of NATO.
So that means if anyone fucks with an
island of Finland or someone fucks with
fucking Norway's fishing rights,
whatever,
we all got to go in and then you're like,
well,
we better be ready for that and we better
understand what the fuck that means.
Cause guess what,
the Russians have been doing fucking
power squats with an AK 47 ready to go.
Uh, we've been sorta eating pop rocks
and drinking coke and fan. I know,
I think, I think playstation
is better than Nintendo.
What's the real with the real difference
between us though is economic, right?
Like for the law and we rush and they
don't know fuck and economy like we do.
Right. I mean, look,
the thing is no difference as far as
like what they can put into the military,
into their budget and the
resources. Well, you know,
Russia and China have always had
a different philosophy, which is,
may have a lot more of it, you know, so
they have more tanks that are Shittier,
but they're out of fucking, you
gotta shoot 10 of them, you know,
Dubai and China used to, that
was their thing. Waves, you know,
they'd have waves of people
and they would literally, your,
your machine gun would over heat
kind of thing. So if you look at it,
we have the best military in the world,
most technologically advanced
military in the world.
But I dunno what the standing army
is and I'm going to get in shit,
no matter what number I say, but let's
say it's 3 million, right. You know,
then you look at Russia,
it's probably 30 and if you
look at China's probably
300 million. Yeah. I mean,
because every, well, I, I believe in
China, look it up. I think at one,
at one point in China,
everybody has to be in the military.
They have 1,000,000,003 people. So, you
know, but yeah, but that's the thing is,
is you can have however many people you
want the most technologically advanced
military in the world, but if you're
fucking with China, you're in trouble.
And if you're fucking with Russia,
you're in trouble. Then it goes to, well,
we have a lot more nukes on them.
And then obviously that's not
a question you went to. Yeah.
That's the worst question you can ever
get into the United States armed forces
standing army. Let's see how many
people we've got. Active personnel,
1,369,000 combat troops was,
that's in total as active personnel.
It's just the Wiki. Yeah. Cause comp,
if you look at combat personnel,
it's usually 20% which is
a staggeringly low number.
It's like 300,000 people's.
Whoa. That's terrifying. Yeah.
This, uh, that's not good.
This idea that we're going to go
to war with someone like Russia to,
that freaks people out too, because we
can't go to worldwide look white gangs.
You Go, no, you don't. You can't go to
war with Russia because a, you know,
whoever, maybe maybe it
would be a tie, let's say.
But then all those nukes,
all you need is one crazy
general on either side. One
crazy motherfucker to say,
you know what,
I'm going to doctor strange love this
shit and I'm just going to let fly. Yeah,
I'm talking to traipse.
Love this shit. But do you,
do you think that there
is an issue though,
the difference between going to war with
someone who doesn't look like what we
perceive to be the quintessential or
you know what? I'm typical. I mean,
you know what?
Yes.
But you know what I'm confused
about is if you look at America,
what would you say the number one
security political problem in America is
today?
Security.
Security issue. Security problem.
Political. Not Political problem.
Like you can't be debt or energy or
whatever. Like a political seat though.
Like you're secure. Yeah. Okay. We can't
be PR and external. External, external,
external. We were worried about terrorism.
Okay, good. Thank you. That was,
what's the number one by by far,
way worse than America in Russia today.
Terrorism.
They have terrorist attacks.
You know,
they had the theater where they were
all killed in the theater. They had,
they just had the subway state,
they blew up two subway stations in
Moscow recently. They had the, the, the,
the school where they killed all the kids,
right?
The AG stands coming up and the Russia,
they have these late,
they have nine eleven's right.
On a yearly basis. Right.
Since then you look at China and say,
what's the biggest external threat
happening in China right now?
Right. Terrorism. So western
China, the youngers are,
the wiggers are fucking going ape shit
in northern China and Outer Mongolia.
And it's causing a huge,
massive,
massive problem within China
where hundreds and thousands
of people being killed
and slaughters and bus stops and
train stops. So just had one recently.
And what's interesting is you say, okay,
the three major powers in the world,
America, China, and Russia, right,
all share the exact same number one enemy,
which is terrorism within their countries,
aligned terrorism.
It's the same group, same
groups. And then you say, okay,
uh, why the fuck wouldn't we just
get together and say, hey guys,
we have exactly the same m and India
by the way, is in there as well.
Why the fuck don't we get
together and say, hey,
this is a huge problem for all of us.
Massive fucking problem
for all of us and Europe.
Put everybody in there and say, why the
fuck don't we get together and say, Hey,
we've got to solve this one way
or tother because it's much the,
the deaths by terrorism. I believe
our number one, China, number two,
Russian number three America.
The why the fuck don't we get to go on
and say let's do something about this
collectively.
Number three America.
But there must be number three all have
in countries that we've invaded to bring
us into number three, right?
Cause of death by terrorism.
I liked the 3000 people that died in
nine 11 and what other attacks? You know,
a few other,
yeah, it would be, it would be a
tax on Americans and foreign soil,
but in China to continue a war,
you have western China,
north western China with users in Russia.
It's continuing of Dagestan you have and
you have all this stuff. And then here,
you know, we have all of our, you know,
I guess it must include
a Afghanistan or Iraq
and a,
Russia's getting that weird spot right
now where their economy is sinking and it
was like a free fall. They
lost 50% of the ruble. Yeah.
In the past two years.
Yeah. It's, it's,
it's a combination of sanctions
and the collapse of oil,
which is the majority of their GDP,
both of which are blaming on us.
Well, how do we fuck with their oil?
We lowered the price of it. Right?
Isn't that part of what's going?
Everyone lowered the price was shale
oil and fracking. We have, you know,
have done a lot to become
energy independent, which I
think is a good thing. Um,
but the glut of shale cheap,
a fracking shale oil has,
has driven the price down
and OPEC hasn't, uh, uh,
decreased supply,
which would theoretically increase it.
Also problems like,
uh,
Venezuela and Iran have sort of
solve themselves in the sense of oil
distribution.
Wow.
The,
when the number of barrels that
the United States produces today,
it's supposed to be as much or
more than anybody in the world.
Like we produced this
yeah. Oils, anybody. Yeah.
We always produced a ton and we just
consumed more than we produce because we
like to consume shit. Um,
you know, but by and large,
the biggest security problem I believe
that we had, including terrorism,
was that our energy dependence upon.
So if you look at Saudi Arabia,
you say,
okay,
these guys are actively
supporting mosques that say,
Wahhabi Islam is good. I e.
That you should not, you know,
you should adopt a fighting a terrorist.
Islam. Um, that was our money, you
know? And so at that point, you know,
we're giving money to Pakistan,
we're giving money to a Saudi,
we're giving money to a, we're giving
money to Iraq. Why? It's crazy.
It doesn't seem sane.
But why oil?
Because we need to fucking oil and and
we need all the oil and you shouldn't
need less oil.
Yeah,
well I think it puts us
in a better position.
It doesn't make them Desperado isn't
it better to keep them our hose?
Thank God I was running the country.
I would, I would continue to,
you know that got him on the hotel that
that question is being answered right
now. That question is being
answered in real time.
You don't want to go head to
head with a hoe, but the thing,
it was a check but because of the,
because of exactly what you're saying,
because of the stratification
of that power system.
That's why you have isis that way.
That's why you have all this shit.
Everyone just thinks isis is a bunch of
dudes who went out fucking hadn't joined
and said, you know what? Why don't we
fucking take out Chi this thunder? No,
what happened is you have a huge
fucking group from all over the world,
international fucking consensus coming
in there and saying we're going to make a
caliphate. And by the way, that caliphate,
because there were a hobbyist say we want
to take over Mecca once they take over
Mecca, if they take over
Mecca, hopefully they don't.
Then you have a real problem because
then you have isis saying we are the pope
and fucking Rome. Thank you very
much. Is that what they want to do?
Is that the only of,
Oh fuck yeah.
That's why Saudi Arabia has shitting
their pants now is because they were
funding all these wahabiists things and
then an isis goes yet we're wahabiists
but where the real wahabiists and
we're coming to take Mecca. Why?
Because if you run Maca, you
run the Sunni world. Right.
And so there,
Saudi Arabia has a lot more to worry
about isis than America does because Saudi
Arabia, because there are real close to
fucking mech and they want to take it,
we need to just get giant cargo planes
like those cargo planes were do skydive
out of and it filled them to the top
with mushrooms and not at the end of it.
You have like a big board where we just
push the mushrooms out the back of the
plane.
What I love is circle what I love is
we'll go on the ground with our whole
military and fight to them. He was saying,
oh, but we were not going to go after.
We'll, we'll bomb isis here
and there. And you're like,
this is as bad as it gets to why
he's using this as bad as it gets.
Isis is Nazi Germany on fucking
steroids, but we're using um, drones,
right?
That's the idea.
They are airstrikes or I should
really distinguish that there's,
I am not involved in the drone strikes,
airstrikes,
airstrikes and Mandera strikes.
And how many Isis soldiers are there?
According to Ben Affleck,
there's like 200 dudes. Is he
correct. What had been Afflecks say?
I don't know who is on
the bill Maher show.
He had some goofy quote that got
chewed apart by Sam. I mean I've, I,
so we embedded with isis for four weeks
last summer and I interviewed and I
hit the brakes. Why'd you
say that? So casually,
we embedded with isis for four weeks.
What the fuck were you
thinking? Dude, first of all,
I did not say casually.
That was, and just assume,
I just assume everyone know it was
in the world and I didn't know we had
something like 45,000,040.
Fuck no, fuck no.
But we have a filmmaker who,
who we worked with in Palestine,
um, we asked if we could go
see what was happening in, uh,
at the time isis now I,
so, and we embedded, uh,
for four weeks they changed names.
The artist formerly known as Isis,
it's ice hole now. I, so I like the
P diddy on steroids or puff daddy.
So we,
we embedded for four weeks with
them all over in Iraq and in Syria.
And we released a, a documentary
one, a ton of awards. It was viewed,
uh, you know, tens of millions
of times, you know, and um,
basically we didn't have any commentary.
We just pressed record.
And uh,
I really enjoyed it because
of that because it wasn't
like look at these fucking
cocksuckers, whatever. It was
like, Hey, your vales not,
cause what they did is they showed us
what life under the Islamic state is and
it's like,
it's like Nazi Germany.
It's like you have to have the veil and
you can't be too happy and you can't
fucking eat too much licorice and
all this shit and uh, you know,
want a ton of awards for it.
We embedded with Isis.
I personally interviewed
a couple of guys from,
my sister was a Canadian guy who
was thought to be dead. He was not.
And I interviewed him.
And what's interesting is,
I mean the numbers vary. Um, but the,
the top end,
but the number the guy was giving
me is they 50,000 foreign fighters.
Now we know that they have
50,000 fighters. The argument is,
is it like 20 or 30,000
foreign and you know,
20,000 Iraqi Syrian or what the,
what the mix up is.
But these are on the ground fighters.
These are not like support
troops or you know,
logistics or mentality.
These are the fucking fighters.
So this is why people should sit up
and take notice is you have, I mean,
for us to mobilize 50,000 fighters
is a huge fucking deal, right?
But they have people coming from America.
We talked to French people in Isis.
We talked to Americans, we talked
to, I talked to Canadians personally,
you know, and we're like,
I don't understand. You're
from America or from Canada.
You're from France or from Germany
or from the UK. You're fighting,
in my mind anyway,
for maybe the worst political
organization around,
but in their mind, because they've
grown up with these well hobbyist, uh,
uh,
mosques that that's the right thing to
do because they need to be well hobbyist
in Mecca for it to be true Islam.
And that's why I think people should take
the next look at Isis because isis is
not going away anytime soon because these
people id logically believe that they
are right.
And the question shouldn't be,
what the fuck's happening with Isis is
the question should be how the fuck could
isis recruit 50,000 people
in fucking six months?
Well,
if you think about what the,
the image of the United States is and how
we've invaded these foreign countries,
Islamic countries,
and the hatred that a lot of the
Islamic radical fundamentalist guys have
towards the United States government.
If we had a similar
enemy to United States,
as overpowering as we are,
is, is invasive as we are.
We have basis in over a hundred countries.
Red Dawn, could you imagine bread,
wake up those fucking dudes
that live in Michigan,
white dudes that let all their guns,
South Dakota and North Dakota
and fucking New Mexico,
Jesus Louise's, you know what kind of a
fucking army if we were invaded. Yeah,
that would be, it would never end
if you United States turned hard.
Never fucking gave us are super serum
or super soldier serums from Captain
America movie. Yeah,
it would be a country.
We're just so fat and so
far ahead of the curve,
but we would get down with
it pretty quick. I mean,
well that's what we saw after nine
11 when I already had, but I think,
I think that you brought
up fucking good point,
which is here's a rack,
right?
And and for a long time we were supporting
Iraq and then we'd support it ran
their biggest enemy and they
wouldn't support a rack again.
And then we'd support around.
Why?
Because we want a cheapo fine
geopolitics actually. Who gives a fuck?
Actually, you know we're hegemonic power.
That's what we have to do. Whatever
the problem is is you say,
okay, we meet up shit.
This is where it gets a bit Wonky, right?
Because you're like, if you wanted,
if you just told the American people
we need to fucking oil and this guy is
fucking fucking with oil,
I think that would have been better than
weapons of mass destruction and going
to the UN and trying to get
everybody behind it and try it.
W we understand that we are
geopolitical player where the policemen,
the world's policemen,
you don't have to make this shit up.
But what happened is they said Al-qaida
is being supported by Sadam Hussein.
Now,
anyone want to have a brain knows that
alcaide is fundamentalist religion and
the bath party was a secular,
they were anti religious.
They were like political thing.
They were,
they didn't want religious extremism
so they weren't how helping out kind of
where are they bad guys is Adamus ain't
a bad guy. Yes, I didn't like him.
He's not my friend.
I don't like him.
But was he fucking Osama bin Laden's
best friend? No, they were enemies.
In any case,
we make shit up and we go in there.
We fucked shit up so
bad for so long that we,
when we leave right after the day we leave
a co a fucking cadre of motherfuckers
come out called Isis,
which make Al Chi to look like a fucking
tea party and take over the country.
Right. It surprising at all. But
hold on. So we go in, we made it up.
We said the Boogie man lives in Iraq.
We fuck it up so bad that when we
leave the Boogie man is twice as big.
And by the way we made them.
Now that is a failure not of our trip,
but off the fucking State Department
and other political fucking cause.
These guys, there was a time when the
British could actually say, you know,
we can make decisions that we are making
decisions that are terribly wrong and
the saddest part about that as people
are paying for that on our side and on
their side with their fucking lives.
But isn't that,
I mean I'm not in any way downplaying
the troops or any military action,
but I'm just looking at it from
a purely objective point of view.
Almost like a mathematics.
He's not a cause and effect
type situation. I mean you,
you enter into our country,
you have what is the number of casualties
of civilians in Iraq? It's staggering,
right? It's like a hundred
to one. It's crazy.
The amount of that were killed supposedly
somewhere around a million. Yes.
Including sanctions because
we cut off medicine and shit.
It's like a million Iraqis.
That's a big number.
What does anybody in their right mind
think the reaction of those people is
going to be unless they're so
completely detached from those people?
On the ground that you don't take that
into account at all when you make your
decisions. That's my long
winded answer to your question,
which is if someone did
that to America and said,
America bombed Russia,
we clearly did not bomb rush or we
didn't help or whatever, they invaded us,
killed a million or 10 whatever the
factor is, 10 million to 20 million.
Everybody including me and you,
we get it.
We said we were going to kill
those motherfuckers. Yeah,
we had all have to get down and
that is what's happening now.
And then everybody's sitting there going,
wow, fuck, we'll just go bomb isis.
Those ices motherfuckers cutting
people's heads off. Fuck Isis. Fuck Isis.
And you're like, I agree.
Fuck. I said I'm a journalist.
They're going to cut my head
off so I don't like them.
But at the same time you're
sitting there going, okay, why?
Why is no one asking?
Why is no one asking,
how the fuck did these
motherfuckers become popular?
How the fuck did they
recruit guys from Virginia?
How did they recruit guys from France?
How do they recruit guys from England?
Where the fuck are these guys coming
from and how did they take over Syria and
fucking Iraq?
When you have every army in the world,
they're in every fucking commando unit
and every intelligence agency and these
fucking bunch of new guys, new kids on
the block took over everybody's shit.
And the reason why is because a,
there's institutional fucking
money funding them. And B,
because we fucked up shit bad on our side.
Now we should take the learnings
that we've done and say, look,
Isis isn't going anywhere unless
we fucking, you know, go ape shit.
Guess what? It's going to make all kind
of look like a tea party. Good Lord.
Right when you think that he's brought
the doom and gloom to the highest level
possible, a new watermark
emerges. This motherfucker,
I actually love life. I know you
do that love life. I love you.
I love life so much. Look, I
eat too much. I drank too much.
I hang out with dudes like you.
I got to say there's nothing
there with drinking too much,
but I'll tell you why because
there's nothing better in life.
And I don't know if you, if you agree
with me, but when you get older,
besides family, cause family for me is
number one. You have, you know your kids,
which are everything, but you get a
bit older, you know, but it's shit.
You have a drink, you have a steak.
You talked to somebody and say, look,
this is important shit.
The greatest thing that we have you and
I is that we can talk about this shit
and people actually listen to us because
I believe that people all over America,
North America, Europe are having
the exact same discussions.
And unless everybody goes, you
know what, that's fucking true.
These guys are being cock suckers and
fuck isis and we got to stop this fucking
sea level rise.
That's the beauty about what we can do
is that we live in a world where we can
talk and have a few drinks and say what
we believe in. And literally you're,
I get it every time like, you
know, hundreds of thousands
and tens of thousands,
Facebook, Twitter, everyone
said, okay good. I'm fucking
down. What do we do next?
I don't fucking know. I'm
not Jesus Christ. We're just
sitting here and saying,
this is what I believe in.
This is what I think the greatest thing
about our lives is that we live a life
where we can have a discussion and it
actually matters and people will listen to
them. You can say, what
do we do next? Well,
I think that's one of the things
that's held back are all cultures,
is the ability to communicate with each
other and find out that we're more alike
than we are different.
We're all just human beings and it
was really difficult to have those
conversations before.
It was really difficult to reach people
all over the world and we look at this,
you know what? Hold on, look
at what you've built here.
You've built a communication center.
You've built a network. Back in the day,
this would be NBC.
People would come in and they'd talk to
her shit and they'd say whatever they
say, and then they leave Walter
Cronkite. You literally built that here.
Now it's a lot less prohibitively
expensive than building NBC.
But that's why whenever I come
here and I tried to come here,
every time I come to la is
because this is the future of,
it's NBC,
but it's NBC for our people.
It's on NBC for everyone. Like NBC
used to, there was three channels.
But one of the things I
love about coming here,
and this is why I get
rankled about censorship,
is Joe Rogan has to be able
to say whatever the fuck
he wants. No matter what.
Shane Smith has to be able to
say whatever the fuck I want,
no matter what you can say I'm wrong.
You can say fuck you Shane,
I hate you. You're not allowed to
shoot me without me. Yeah, but,
but like while we have freedom of
speech and while we have communication,
why don't we have all this shit?
We should celebrate the shit out of it
and we should tell everybody else out
there that they should celebrate the
shit out of it because that's what true
freedom is. And last we're allowed to
say whatever the fuck we want to say.
There is no such thing as freedom.
There is no such thing as true freedom.
If you can't express yourself 100%
it's number one fucked of thing.
You can buy a gun,
you can do this.
And if you can't say what you fucking
believe without somebody pointing a gun to
your head, that was what the
Gestapo did. The Gestapo said,
you can't say that it will fuck you up.
Well,
the idea is that they're symbiotic because
you need the gun to be able to say,
hey, fuck you. I'm going
to say whatever I want.
I can protect my body with this weapon,
your weapon.
It's the only thing that I'm wanting
to go to a gun fight whole world.
It shouldn't get to the gunfight does.
We should be able to say whatever the
fuck we want. And that's in violent.
And by the way,
that's what we should be fighting for
when we talk about human rights and when
we talk about shit,
a lot of time like we were going on,
Sadam Hussein was a bad guy.
Yeah, there's a lot of bad guy.
The Hutus and the Tutsis were fucking
kill him the fuck out of each other.
The exact same chatty.
Exactly.
So it wasn't about him being a bad guy
because there's a lot of bad guys out
there. However, what we should fight for
his freedom of speech and that's why he,
Charlie up door is an important thing
that everybody in the world is coming out.
They're not protesting.
They're saying, you know what?
Everybody should be able to say
whatever the fuck they want.
And I believe in that.
Well,
I think anybody who doesn't
believe in that as a fool,
but there's a lot of fucking people,
but there's a lot of people.
Did you hear about what the
fuck is going on? There was a,
there was another attack while this
app to this Charlie Hebdo thing is Boko
Haram.
Yeah.
That was 2000 people killed in
Nigeria by Islamic extremest. Yes.
But we didn't hear about that
because that's what I'm saying. Yeah,
well that's true. It's not a fucking
weird thing, man. That's weak.
It's racism and it's Africa fatigue and,
and quite frankly,
the different issues,
right?
One of them is attacking someone because
of freedom of speech. Yeah. This is,
this is some other, there's some other
motivation, right? I mean there is sadly,
there is Africa fatigue, much like there's
Afghanistan fatigue or a rack fatigue.
I mean, how about if, let's take a rack
for example, we left Iraq and said,
mission accomplished, we
won good, goodbye. And we
left. The story didn't end,
but we left. Boom. Isis Bank, biggest
story in the world. Oh, well how,
where the fuck did these guys
come from? Well, if you would, uh,
not just slept there,
you would have known.
And I think that there's
Africa fatigue for sure.
Like Ebola actually continues to rise.
The deaths continue to rise.
If we haven't contained it.
It's now in Sierra Leone and Guinea and
it's fucking getting worse in, in, in, um,
in, in Liberia is out of the news cycles.
Therefore it must be fucking over.
We saw, must have sent the
pill. That works. No, the
deaths fucking increase. The,
the, the, the, the, the, uh,
opportunity for contagion increases and,
and everybody,
that's why we're doing our 24 hour news.
And that work cause you're like who
gives a fuck about the news cycle?
They found the plane so
therefore every like who cares?
Like when we left Iraq,
that's when the problem started and
nobody paid any attention while isis built
up.
You know you look at West Africa and you
say Ebola is fucking still raging but
now it's fucking the nurse didn't
get it in Euston is a world. Okay.
I mean there is Africa fatigue,
there is Iraq fatigue,
there is around fatigue and it's like
now we're going to enter into domestic
elections and we'll be, we'll be
fascinated with what goes on there.
Well it's almost like it never ends like
this is a fractal equation because as
you start looking at all
the various aspects of our
culture that we could change,
it could be better and we
look at life and death,
but that's just look at the desks that
we have in this country because the
cigarettes,
I don't have anything,
any problem with people smoking
cigarettes if you truly want to write.
But the fact that that's
like sort of this ignore if,
if everyone stood back,
if everyone,
like the entire government like had like
a holes anti cigarette week where they
said in every day on the news
they broadcast is special
about this is a person
who started smoking when they're
16, who either are, when they're 15,
getting half their throat removed
and show that shit on television.
How long would it be before the numbers
just radically dropped and the number of
people that you saw dead. Yeah, every
year radically dropped from cancer.
It would be gigantic.
Huge.
But then we get back into
the whole freedom of speech
thing, which is, you know,
what isn't that freedom of speech?
It is free to but like when,
when government gets involved in
social issues and messaging thing.
Well but what's the social
issue? But that's a social
issue if you look up. Okay,
but let's look at the social issue
that will say no, that was uh,
um, Obamacare, which by the way,
calling like a affordable healthcare.
Obamacare is funny cause
you're just labeling Obama.
And if you look at it just as if you
take a step back, and by the way,
I don't want to get embroiled
into it cause I am not an expert.
But globally you're like universal health
care is like a thing like people you
know should be yeah or
so health care whenever.
Now granted I come from Canada where
universal health care when I grew up was
good.
However that said,
I'm not a huge believer in the government
running anything because governments I
believe,
cause I grew up in a government town are
inefficient and they spend 80% of the
money on themselves and 20% on the thing.
So I'm not like a huge
believer in government doing
anything that said universal
care for the richest country in the world
seems like fucking we should have it.
That became the greatest single debate
and probably the worst thing for
definitely a Obama,
but for sure maybe up there and top
five for the Democratic Party and, and,
and essentially it was like a thing
that if you looked at it in the world
context,
every rich industrial country as
universal healthcare. So it's a boring,
it's a fucking given.
It's a nothing.
And that became such a fucking huge
thing because it was the government
interfering into
your private life. Right.
And because of that,
the extrapolation became a thing.
And I found that to be an amazing litness
test on the American psyche because
you sit there and say, I mean
quite frankly, who the fuck cares,
right? You know, how much money
were miss spending on healthcare?
I get taxed more in America than I
did in Canada in Communist Canada.
I get taxed more in America and the
fucking money gets thrown down the toilet.
I, you know, I would,
I would be a fucking tea
party motherfucker on the
taxation side because you tax
me the saving Canada, but the schools
suck in the hospital, suck, whatever.
But you have to have universal healthcare.
You cannot be the richest country in the
world and have fucking people dying on
the street and just rotting there
because, well, fuck, you know, they,
they couldn't afford it. Now
was it implemented? Well,
no, it wasn't messaged. Well,
no,
but the political war that went over
over something as stupid as fucking
universal, universal healthcare, stupid
to argue about. Yeah. Just becomes like,
we're going to fucking
argue about everything now.
Every single fucking thing we are going
to, we're going to argue about it.
Can we fund the government?
We're going to argue about fucking
are we going to pay our own debt?
We're going to argue about,
you know what shoe we put on the right
foot versus the left one and that's the
problem is if you talk to portray us
who now I was up against charges but a
secretary gates,
anyone,
they will all tell you the greatest
fear or the great story of the greatest
problem for American security is
the inaction of the government.
The government cannot enact fucking
anything and that is the problem that you
have today is you have something like
like affordable health care act just
becoming a huge politicized issue where
someone should have just said, look,
it's going to cost us 0.01% of the fucking
thing to make universal healthcare,
which we can't fucking
hold her how it heads up.
If we don't have just fucking do it was
shut up and fucking get on with fucking
whatever the fuck else it is.
It became the number one political
issue of last year. And guess what?
It's a nonissue. It's a non issue.
We're sitting here, we don't have water,
we don't have fucking water. Think
already fixed that Bro. Fix it. Fix it.
Sell my pipeline pipeline to Antarctica.
It's the pipelines of the big ice ICU.
No problem dude. You just develop like
a funnel. You know what I'm saying?
And to funnel Marco's,
it'll just be like eco warriors
with dreads and sandals.
Yeah,
we would find out that anyway,
it's been peeing in the funnel and
everybody would get really pissed. Yeah.
This is bullshit. There's
no, there's no fix.
But I think we've been in
constant turmoil for so long.
I wonder if when something happens like
isis or something along those lines
where there's a real like
military movement against
this big machine is America.
I wonder if it excites like some sort
of garden DNA. Yeah. Got It. Yeah.
Cause I know, I know. I know that
I'm hunting does, and you know,
what else does farming man, you
know, growing your own vegetables,
there's something about plucking your
own vegetables and slicing into it and
making a salad with that tomato that
amazed that there's something primal. Oh,
it's good. I believe that that rule would
also tastes better. It does. It does.
I was listening to hold on.
It probably tastes better just in general.
It's probably better
for it, you know? But,
but psychologically it tastes
better because I made that 100%.
Definitely. I couldn't agree
more, but I feel like VOD could,
that I make doesn't tastes
better than this. You make vodka.
I've made every boozy you, I'll taste
it tastes like fucking it's potato.
It's just,
you can make a still and fermentation
and it tastes like everything tastes like
Shitty, awful moonshine, terrible vodka.
What they do is they just refine away
just so it tastes like nothing because you
never, I mean, vodka doesn't taste
like, hey, just add some shit.
And have you ever seen those tests?
You know that that doesn't taste like
Jack and they put it into the barrels? Oh,
they barrels the barrels,
stain it and taste it and that's otherwise
it would just tastes like fucking bar.
Oh alcohol's just alcohol.
Right.
And add the barrels and the whiskey
barrels like coal and stuff. Right.
They burn them burn. That's why
it's so yummy and it's fucking good.
Best Jack 10 is the best. I'm going, you
know what Merck, but hold on, you can,
you can order all the, the, the super
high end shit and whatever else by,
I believe Jack is the best tasting,
you know, but it's not bourbon.
Apparently it's a mash or calm,
calm of our great country.
I do, I do like Jack,
what I was going to say was that
someone took a cheap bottle of vodka.
I import it through those Brita water
filters and did it like seven or eight
times and it came out as good as
any vodka. Smirnoff always wins.
SMIRNOFF's like $5 a leader and it's
all and they always win the taste test
cause you know why? Cause it tastes like
fucking nuts. They put sugar in there.
Well, I don't think they put shit
and they just put alcohol in there.
That is weird. That drinks
are not supposed to taste
good. They taste good. Yeah.
You fucking pussy. What do you got? A
little umbrella and you drink in a cherry.
That's true. That's true. That's weird.
Cause I always, when I was a kid,
I used to pretend this says
something about the psyche,
but I would drink coca cola
out of like a shot glass.
Oh Jesus Christ kid.
And I always thought this is the greatest.
And by the way,
if they had a drink that was like coca
cola but like was like I would drink the
fuck out of that. Cause
I, I love Coca Cola.
I try not to talk about that cause he
have an issue with that fucking hate Pepsi
don't drink it often will not drink.
Jim Norton is the same way by
the Pepsi is like a sugary Wa.
Coca Cola is the greatest carbolic
acid that ever existed. The, the radio.
But you know, people used to
have the taste tests. Right.
I don't know why I'm looking to
you for vindication. I took Jamie,
they would do the taste
test and you'd be like,
if you can't taste the difference
between coke and Pepsi, you're fucking,
I hate your guts because
they're completely different
fucking thing. In any case,
I always pretend and I've always been
waiting for a drink that's going to be as
powerful and amazing and hit you as hard
as a coca cola and every time you have
one it's just, mine are really
disappointing. I love whiskey. Right?
But if whisky tastes like Coca Cola
fucking drink alone, you can't. Yeah.
If whiskey Tracy like cocoa, we'd
have a real problem. It's contrary.
You don't have to feel it.
I think one of the good things about
one of the good things about
whiskey or about Tequila,
you feel it when it's going down.
You know you've done something terrible.
Like you take a shot of Jack Daniels
and it hits you and just like, well,
you brought up a very good point because
I just got back from a week in Vegas.
Right.
And it's a very good point because if
you asked me what I really like to drink,
like if I wanted to drink,
so I like Irish whiskey,
I liked shitty Irish whiskey on ice.
And then number two would be like,
I like to drink. You know, we,
you and I like meat. So like I like to
eat a steak with a glass of red wine.
I think state with a glass of red wine.
It was like a reaffirmation of life.
Right?
But what the fuck do I really
drink? I drink vodka soda. Why? Why?
Cause it's a fucking drunks,
frank.
And you can drink when you're
at Vegas and you're playing,
you can drink 50 vodka sodas and just
be like, there's the water in there.
It's the purest of the spirit. And was
like, if you drink 50 fucking Jack,
you're fighting the crew Pa,
you're shitting on the floor,
you're running a vodka. Soda
is like, you're rehydrate.
It's a drunk drink. You can drink a vodka
soda forever. Also. Do you ever get sick?
Like, you know when you're drinking
a lot of whiskey at the end of it,
you're like, I never want to drink
another whisk again. Vodka soda.
You wake up the next day
and say, Oh, Vodka Soda.
Like that's scary because I'm now
so old and I've drank so much booze.
Then I'm like,
well can you drink 5,000 of those cars
if you can rank 5,000 of them, I'll go,
which is a vodka soda. That
seems ridiculous. So you,
so you honestly believed that
whiskey gets you into fights.
I think that's going on brown
liquor as a punchy liquor,
my friend and you know it doesn't,
uh,
I come from a long line brick carrying
savages or I'm always drank brown liquor,
eyes the clear liquor.
Brown liquor is a punchy liquor.
I don't like the clear liquor. I drink
the Mexican version of clear liquor.
I don't trust that Russian shit. Well,
so Keela we'll keep you up block.
We'll keep you up. I'm always been Jack
Brown liquor. We'll keep you punching.
You know that. That's what the fuck
you, why do you think you do a fighter?
You got the kettle bells and
kicking in the fighting. He's like,
Jack Daniel's a poor decision making.
I don't think it's the
carbon inside the barrel.
I mean you yourself said that alcohol
is the same effect. It's, it's,
it's shine with a bit of fucking
burn wood in it. But by the way,
it's a gorgeous one of the
managers at the comedy store,
Terrence has a fuck some
fucking ridiculous moonshine
that he brought from pack
home. Oh yeah. Moonshine to wake you up.
But the reason why I like
cheap Irish was some, yeah.
The reason why I like cheap Irish whiskey,
new glasses is a,
cause they run it through Pete, which
is, you know, bog bricks that they like.
It tastes like fucking grass basically.
And it's just moonshine.
It tastes like grass. I'm like,
Oh fuck whiskey. I love it.
I just fucking moonshine.
GRAPPA is just fucking moonshot.
But they put it in the,
in the fancy bottles and shit and your
lights fucking moonshot. It's disgusting.
It's the same fucking thing.
Yeah.
My grandparents used to have that
shit will just drink it after a meal.
I don't know.
Just to tolerate each other.
I've got to say that we've talked
about how the world's about 10.
I've never felt better about humanity,
that I feel bad because
I've had a few drinks.
I don't know why alcohol is considered
a depressant cause I'm fucking euphoric
as fuck when I drink it. After the effect,
it's, he crushes your immune system.
It's immunosuppressant. It's bad for
protein synthesis. This Brad is new.
Hydrates you, it's, I know
it's bad for fat burning.
I've experienced that first thing,
different kinds of lunchtime.
We have the real issue with alcohol is
the dehydration and the liver toxicity.
Oh, that's it. Yeah. We're doing a
piece, actually I can I be fucking,
uh, positive for once in my misery life.
You do want a piece that's positive. Okay.
So my favorite piece I've ever done,
I'm doing right now and I was at this,
uh, conference. This is moonshine and, uh,
well now it's about to get
unintelligible if I get into that shit.
But I'm going to,
so I'm going to try to get my
last intelligence story out.
So I was at this conference
and there was just amazing.
Um, uh, I dunno,
presentation about a guy
who was a researcher,
HIV researcher and h they are,
they're like HIV,
HIV, uh, you know each t-cells, it eats,
it eats human cells is amazing at
eating shit. It's amazing at eating.
Sell moonshine.
Now you're going to get me fucked up.
I'm going to start crying again. So what
are you saying? AIDS. You have aids.
Okay. So whoa, that's good.
That's actually the best
shit. That's pretty good.
I have here.
That's a real God damn America again.
Like I'm going to have one more
before I finished this. By the way,
the story is going to fuck you up.
So everybody turn it up now
because this is important. Okay?
Okay.
So they figure out HIV is
amazing at eating t-cells,
right? So they say,
what if like a pit bull,
we starve the HIV and then we
only feed it cancer, right?
Guess what happens?
It's fucking works like a charm.
So they starve the HIV, they
genetically reintroduce it. So if it,
if HIV doesn't eat your t cells, it's
not a problem to you, but at each cancer,
so it's a cancer reader. So I'm watching
this thing go and hold on. When HIV AIDS,
cancer, cancer, each HIV, HIV
is an EAD or HIV, each cells,
right?
So like why don't we starve it for
t cells and feed it cancer cells.
And it worked. In fact, they'd
been in four years of trials,
a hundred percent success, right? And
it's going to, it's, it's a blood cancer,
so it's a leukemia. And so what,
what happened? So I started saying,
well holy fuck cause my mom had
cancer and my step mom died of cancer,
of everyone's had somebody affected
by cancer. So I'm like, Holy Shit,
they reengineered HIV to
go out and any cancer.
And then they're like,
well actually now what they're doing is
a reengineering viruses for different
cancers. So for example,
the Mayo Clinic re, re, re,
uh,
engineered measles and they're injecting
like a billion measles into a bone
cancer in the bar. And you
see a PR, one woman had, uh,
a golf ball size tumor in her head.
And then like the injector with measles
and the fucking measles eat the cancer,
like eat it. And so the, the, the, the,
which was previously an operable just
goes away. What the fuck? So there's,
there's, in Houston they're
doing it, uh, in, in,
in Mayo Clinic in Penn state.
And uh, in Ottawa, Canada,
the guy who first discovered it was a
guy who came across this paper where
hookers,
who used to get cervical cancer,
all she used to get rabies because a,
they were living in squalor.
So they would inject
the women with rabies.
And then there were cervical cancer
would go away because the viruses eat to
cancer. So this is, by the way, I'm,
I must be drunk because I'm giving you
my biggest scoop on HBO that's coming up
on our new season. But, so I went
to interview all these doctors.
I went to say like,
what the fuck's going on?
And they've re-engineered these
viruses that used to kill us, right?
To go eat cancer. And I'm
like, is this the first step,
not just for a treatment that
isn't, um, a radiation or, uh,
um, go on pharmaceutical
base. Yeah. Chemo,
Chemo, Chemo, uh, but
actually, uh, uh, know,
uh, treatment that doesn't
fuck you up and that, yeah.
And puts it you in recession,
they're like,
we're looking at the first step towards
a cure. So this is the biggest story
or the opening scene in 28 days later.
Oh, oh, oh, yeah. Right, right, right,
right, right. Well, they actually,
so they re-engineer, they reengineer
the virus. The virus, for example,
the measles virus actually comes from
1953 and it's the kid whose throat culture
they took that we've been using as a
measles virus for the last however long
these guys in Houston
or using a cold virus,
which were all immune to the HIV one,
they actually reprogram so
that it doesn't, uh, uh,
eat our t cells.
But what's incredibly interesting about
that is these guys figured out that what
happened was cancer puts our immune system
to sleep and so that viruses activate
our immune system. So the virus just
goes into the cancer, says, here it is.
And then the immune system goes and
eats it. So for the past six months,
I've met the top five or six medical
teams in the world as they explain this
shit to me and I'm thick as fuck.
So I didn't get half of it.
But what's interesting about it is the
first step to curing cancer caused by the
shit that used to kill us because measles
used to kill like 150 million people a
year. It was a fucking
worst thing you could get.
Now the measles brings all the fucking
white cells and eats the cancer.
It's absolutely fantastic.
And that's my happy thing before
we get drunk on the moonshine.
Give you some more on that.
Excuse me.
That's insane. Yeah, that makes sense.
And it also seems terrifying
because if they fucked that up,
then you got some crazy,
well they go through incredible protocols
and I wish I could just show you this
stuff, but I'm covered in
NBC Dwu suits and Shit. They
go through very, and the uh,
you know, the, they're, they're,
they're making sure that the viruses
are done in the correct way and stuff,
but I've got to say, oh yeah,
but how it all happens is there,
they're like, it happened by mistake.
Like it happened by like, oh,
this fucking we're working on HIV.
That thing actually eats cancer,
you know? And, and I think that,
you know, when I look at stuff, I'm
like, we can solve these problems.
We can fix these problems. When we
get on here, we're always like, wow,
fucking Russia as this and isis is this.
We can fix the problems.
We just have to foot people
on it. And My, you know,
Larry Page always says the guy runs.
Google is always like,
that's a zero million dollar problem.
Meaning if it's a problem,
only if you put zero million dollars into,
you pick up $1 million and
the guest what you saw,
zero million dollar problems.
Yeah.
There's a lot of those to the lungs, just
on purpose. And I don't mean on purpose,
meaning there's some sort of
a grand scheme, sort of a,
the overlying conspiracy
to the way the world runs.
I often wonder the way people behave,
even the way you see
people behave when they,
when they know they're in a relationship
where their husband's never going to
leave or their wife has never going to
leave, or they know they're in a job.
Like there's certain college professors
when they get tenure become preposterous
human beings. And one of the reasons
is that they can't get fired.
They have this really ridiculous power
and people tend when they have power to
explore the limits of it. It's
just, it's almost an inherent, yeah.
I've been listening to the last and it
was like maybe the fourth or fifth time
in just the last year that I've listened
to this Dan Carlin series on the
Mongols. It's a wrath of the
cons that's on hardcore history.
This podcast is to change cause
I'm fascinated. It's the greatest.
If Dan Carlin's podcasts is the
greatest podcast the world's ever known,
it shouldn't be called a podcast cause
it's too good. It's, it's, it's this,
it's essentially a dramatic version of
like history and not just the Margoles
but everything from like world war
one to do. There's so much shit to,
this guy covers in such as
incredible dramatic fashion.
But as I'm listening to these tales
of carnage and conquest and all,
and I'm wondering like, what the fuck
is it that compels people to, to,
to operate in this way?
Like what is it about someone who
gets in power and abuses that power,
whether it's a priest or whether it's a,
you know,
a politician or a police officer. Great
question. What the fuck is it? Like,
is it just something that [inaudible]
like ingrained in us to resist,
like to,
to have the strength to resist opposition
so that when the opposition isn't
there and you have ultimate power,
you spool up your power to
ultimately resist opposition again,
it's like you gather up your
resources when you have control. Yeah.
I mean it almost seems
like this weird sort of a,
a cyclical thing that's very
difficult to escape. Yes.
Very, very difficult to escape.
And I think that that's,
that's the one thing that troubles most
of us, most of us rational thinking.
People who live in urban environments
or don't have to worry about anything
other than like normal, petty
bullshit, they occasional crime.
What we're worried about is like,
what the fuck is going on in the Congo?
What the fuck is going on in Afghanistan?
What the fuck is going on in Crimea?
What? What? What are these, these worlds
that we don't ever want to see in,
in fucking Tribeca?
What are these worlds that we see?
Right?
We're on the right page at the right time.
I'm just going to give you
one anecdote of exactly that,
which is I believe we're
sort of the same kind of guy.
We grew up in the same year.
It's way different than you bitch,
settle down while you're away.
Tougher and stronger.
You're way more bold anywhere. You're
a fucking button. World Traveler.
I had a real and occasional I had her.
I still am going to take you to find,
by the way, remember one of the
last times I was on here, I like,
we should go to Liberia
to find the aids island of the
monkeys to guess what happened. Ebola.
So it's a good thing we
didn't go aids a bully, bully,
bully eats everything. Maybe
we need aid, state aid.
I'm really not worried about aids.
I'm going to tell you that I'm worried
about Ebola. I was worried about it.
I'm not even worried about it. Paul.
I'm worried about the flu. You know why?
Because I flu kills more people
than the goal every fucking year.
Not really number one killer before
World War One was, you know the flu.
You know what the number one killer,
almost universally the entire history
of the human race's death, malaria,
malaria and old hills and all
day, all day. Just all day I'm at,
I'm at midnight of my ecological,
environmental and a whatever it is,
evolutionary clock. So I'm fucked.
But if I could just hold on,
but you brought up an
amazing point and I just,
because I had to deal with this
recently and it was a big t,
you sober up and listen to the
podcast for you make tests team.
It was a big epiphany for me
when I said I have a penis. No,
it was, I woke up one
night and uh, you know,
I used to sleep fucking, you
know, 12 hours later. Now I
wake up, I don't know why,
but I woke up and it was my daughter's
first day of school. Right. And so,
you know,
I got to take my daughter to the first
day at school and I was thinking about
school and I'd always been like, you
know, I went to sort of public school,
rough schools and I think that's
where I got to where I am.
Because schools just bullshitted
to curriculum everywhere you go.
But you learn to pecking order,
you learn a lot of other shit besides
the fucking one plus one equals two.
You learn where you are and what
you do and you learn how to fight.
You learn how to not fight and
do whatever you want in any case.
So I was thinking a lot about my daughter
going to school because she's has a
different life to me cause I,
you know,
I grew up poor and she has a different
life to me. And then I was thinking,
you know, my daughter now is about
to go to school for 25 fucking years.
You go to school for 25 years. Why?
Because you want to have a career.
What's the career?
While a career hopefully is something
that you like doing and you make some
money and maybe you make a difference
or at least you convinced yourself you
make a difference and you know you're
making enough money to maybe buy a house
and maybe you can retire somewhere warm
cause fucking cold makes your arthritis
right. He can, I'm literally
thinking about like life,
you know, cause cause you,
you know,
like I went to school and then I worked
and then you've got a career and then
you tried this and you did all this shit.
And I had been at war.
I realize I've been at war
since I was five years old.
I fought every kid in the school yard
and then I tried to get in the fucking
this and I tried to play
football and whatever the
fuck else. I was always a war.
I was at war with my brother.
We fought every day of our lives,
and then when I got out of school,
I started a company. That company,
I was always at war, right? All of
a sudden I woke up one day, okay.
I went to school, I got my career,
I got to work with my best friends.
I became a billionaire, right?
Doesn't happen. I got the a plus.
I got the fucking a plus and
I'm sitting there going, okay,
I don't have to go to school anymore.
I don't have to work anymore.
I don't have anything to do anymore.
I can move to fucking my private island,
put my Amedeus.
We gone put the fucking pony tail,
but plug up the ass and ride my fucking
horse into the sunset. Just got real.
Now why are you getting up in the morning?
What do you have to fucking do? Why are
you doing it? And they'll look at you.
You are a fucking big star on TV or
the number of fucking voice of the MMA.
You're got a huge comedy career going
and you do whatever the fuck you want to
do. You're done. You won, you won.
You got an a plus in the game of life.
You got an a plus. I got an a plus. Guess
what? I don't have to do anything, right?
I have no more chips on my shoulder.
I have no more demons to exercise.
What the fuck gets me up in the
morning, right? And then I said,
you know what gets me up in the fucking
morning fun doing this shit with you
going out there and saying, hey, by
everybody you can listen to me or not.
But ANTARTICA is fucking melting.
And if I don't say something about that,
then I can't look.
My daughter in the eye when I feed her,
her Kraft macaroni and cheese would be
burger for conviction as good for you.
It isn't, shouldn't give those kids. I,
I most of it,
but I can't look my fucking
kids in the face unless I say,
guess what? We got to fix
Washington doesn't work. We got,
we have to fucking do something about
global warming or we're all foc to now me
and you were still going to be okay.
We'll be all right because I'm much long,
longer live, but our kids, and by the way,
and I love your kids and
you have beautiful kids and
I have beautiful kids in
our family. We love our kids.
I, I don't give a fuck about me.
I had a lot of tough on,
I did a lot of coke and drag it out of
booze and had a lot of sex and all that
shit. But you're like, guess
what? Like we, you know,
and so at this point you're like, I can
either ride off into the sunset and say,
fuck it. I'll sit on an island beach and
I'll drink fucking miss gala every day.
Or you can go out there and say,
no matter what,
I'm going to kick against the pricks.
I'm going to say this ain't
fucking right by the way.
What you're saying is bullshit.
I'm going to go talk, by the way,
I'm going to go interview Putin, I'm
going to interview and I'm going to say,
what the fuck are you doing?
And by the way,
guess who I'm interviewing after Puente.
I'm interviewing Obama and I'm going
to say what the fuck's going on? Why?
Because why the fuck not?
And that's why I always get excited
about coming on this show is because this
show is democracy in action. You have
millions of fucking people listening.
And guess what?
Unless we say something,
unless we wake up from our
volume and booze induced stupor,
nothing's going to fucking happen.
So why the fuck are you doing it?
That's the question you should ask
yourself from 2015 not am I going to lose
weight now I'm going to
read more fucking books,
not am I going to go wear sketchers
instead of Nike's. It should be.
Why the fuck do I
get up in the fucking morning and now
we're very lucky motherfuckers that were
posed economic and we can fucking say,
I'm going to get up in the
morning because of this.
I like how the 1% is relabeled
themselves post economic.
Well,
I'm the newest,
I'm the newest of the 1% and
I'm giving it all away. Cause I,
I'll tell you one thing. Money means a
fuck of a lot when you don't have it.
By my old man told me the only thing
that ever made any sense about money,
he said, life is like your shit
sandwich. The more bread you have,
the sheet you have to eat. But once
you get it, once you get that a plus,
she just say, fuck it. You
know what I'd like to do?
I would like to buy 20 million acres.
We'll say no one's
allowed to fuck with that.
You can't fucking do shit
with that fucking land.
I'm just gonna fucking leave it because
that's one of the only things you can do.
That's a pure good. Just leave
the land. Don't fucking mine it.
Don't fucking pison and don't shit in it.
Don't put Joe's tuna,
bards and Tequila boom,
boom room in there.
Just leave it fucking gorgeous
because fucking that's,
that's that's God had to me is nature.
Well I think one of the things that's
changing in our world is that more people
have uh,
the ability to communicate.
They might not be able to communicate
on the scale that is like a podcast like
this, but they have the ability to express
themselves to us. And maybe, you know,
if you are on Twitter or Facebook or you,
you,
you ran into him in some
form of social media,
you might read what they said
and take it into account.
So something about them trying to express
themselves has some sort of a meaning.
One of the things that has the most
impact for those people is someone who can
reach millions of people who
represents their points of view.
Because most of our field guys,
I'm, that's not happening.
Rogue and Brian, Stan,
he was on my podcast this week. He can,
when I can, I don't have skeletons.
I got graveyards.
This guy.
I'm pretty sure if you have graveyard
concentration camps were all good but
all be your office or your breath or
your press secretary to warm up for my
workout.
I'm not into one.
I would say to everybody out there,
the Joe Rogan would be the
greatest political candidates.
No, no. It'd be terrible because
I have other shit I want to do.
I'm not going to stop commentating
for the UFC. I love that.
I'm not going to stop doing standup.
I love that.
I'm not going to stop podcasting.
I'm not going to stop hanging out with
my kids and taking care of my family.
So where's my time? Well that's
true. It doesn't exist but,
but this is just, it's not just as
good as being a president, but it's,
it's far as like what I can do with who
I am and what personality I've sort of
developed along this path of life.
If I wasn't me and I saw me and I said,
hey man,
you should talk about this shit
cause this is kind of weird.
This is kind of fucked up.
My obligation is to do that.
And your obligation that as well.
And I think that's what you're saying.
I used to play pool like it did to
a degenerate level. High fashion.
Well I never played professional but
I played some [inaudible] whacked out.
You were good.
I wasn't good to compare it to people
that were good. But my point being,
I know you were a good
cause you played with it.
The people that are really good at pool,
almost universally they're gamblers
almost universally all I'm a,
there's a few guys in Europe but the
American players like almost all of them,
what they call match up and
the guys who are the best,
they always look at pool as what
the ultimate thing is winning.
And what money is is just fun.
Coupons. Yeah, just pull coupons.
You pass those back and forth. You don't
worry about the money. You're trying.
I'm not trying to accumulate money.
Well you're trying to do
is when the big score,
I worried about money a lot cause I,
I left home at 14 and I was broke
and I worried about the top 14,
14 and I worried about when
I left home I was a bad guy.
How bad? Fairly medium. No medium
guy. I was medium bad because I,
you can't be that bad in Ottawa,
Canada, but I was as bad as it gets. Um,
but I got to say like,
you know,
money consumed me for a long time.
A M B I had a big old chip on my shoulder.
I would say what?
What fueled me for 75% of my life was
spite because I would say I'm going to
fucking do this. And they'd
rolled her eyes and say, Shane,
you're a fucking arse hole
Shane your bullshit or whatever.
And like just recently I'm,
when I'm going to launch a news network
and they're like, oh fuck Shane,
you piece of shit. Fuck you.
Same family. No Mom, my family,
your family. My family is awesome.
I haven't my family. No, no,
I'm just saying people, people on
the world compete it a, sorry, sorry.
But you let family's house
when you were 14 yeah,
but not because they were mean or
shitty cause it was crazy. Yeah.
I was a old 14 yeah. But I
was like, I was like, Nah.
It was the same height I am now. I looked
old. I was working as a bartender. I was,
I was screwing chicks so older than me.
I was getting drunk.
You were a bartender at 1414 well this
is Canada to back in the fucking day when
it was like, well, right. Who
gives a fuck? And it was, I
was a punk kid by the way.
I had a great time bartending at
14 and sling and coke and stuff.
But the thing is, is like, whoa, whoa,
you slump coke at 14 yeah. What? When,
but when, don't use slang. Coca 14
no, funny that is, you're like, yeah,
well I learned,
I'm all my business acumen being a
drug dealer because it's pretty fucking
simple.
You have to make a margin and you have
to do this and you have to mitigate risk
and all this stuff. And then it went
to eastern Europe and I sold money,
bought and sold money because you can
make money, a lot of money on arbitrage.
Right?
So the thing is is
money was outsized for me for a long time.
It was just, it was, it was, it
was a monkey on my back. And,
and success was based on money.
Whenever,
now the most arrogant fucking
thing in the world you can say is,
I don't give a fuck about money.
Right? Because guess what?
Everybody gives a fuck about
money because that's how you eat.
But the one thing, and it was Spike
Jones, actually, we, when we go away,
every once in a while we go to the top
of the mountain and we fucking talk about
shit and I, and, and he was like,
you're too concerned about money because
I am literally a poor guy who was
concerned about money and he's literally
a guy who never give a fuck about money.
And that's why he's more successful than I
am. Wait, wait, Whoa, whoa. Just say guys,
more successful than you.
After you said you're a billionaire,
let me turn this up. But
no, no, but hold on buddy.
Richard and a billionaire can go
fuck himself, but I'm going to tell,
I'm going to tell you something
about being a billion,
a billion or it doesn't mean anything
because guess why? Well, why? Well,
I'm going to tell you I'm going to,
that's a budget horseshoe, but hold on.
I'll tell you why. Because I'm
going to give it all. Well,
I'm not going to give it all away and
we're going to buy a bunch of land because
I believe in nature. I love seeing
people compete for it. Yeah.
And die and I'm just going to leave it.
That's going to be my thing.
But what I will say is,
it's true, it's true.
Money won't buy you happiness,
but guess what?
Your family not having to worry about
where the next rent checks coming from.
You know, being able to fucking feed your
kids, all that shit. That is important.
Incredibly important. It takes the stress
away, but more importantly it goes, okay,
now take all that shit
out of the equation.
What the fuck are you going to do
today, right, with everything you know,
look at you. You're a powerful guy.
You got all these people listen to you.
What are you going to do? Guess
what? Joe Rogan could say, fuck you.
I'm going to drive my fucking car.
I'm going to go bow hunting.
I'm going to fucking go to uh,
[inaudible] and fucking lie on the beach.
What are you doing?
And you're fucking sitting here with
me doing the back to back podcast,
talking about shit, challenging people,
putting information to people's minds.
I don't have to ever work again. Why
am I sitting here on the fucking Rogan?
But I could be doing USA today.
I can be doing fucking 60 minutes.
Why am I doing the Rogan podcast?
Because this Anderson Cooper
hit on you because I heard,
because this is important and we always
get to this at the end of the day,
is there is a movement of likeminded
people who have the a plus who go,
I don't give a fuck about da plus.
I don't give a fuck about the money.
I don't give a shit about you are fucking,
you are fucking biggest star and
I'm forget the network, but come on.
What's the net where ABC, CBS, NBC
thinking about is what are you doing now?
You're literally hold on.
You're literally spending your own
fucking money to have shit heads like me.
Come on here and talk to people. I know
every time we get drunk, which I am now,
I get all boozed up and says, but this is
democracy in action. This is important.
And by the way, you took your a plus and
said, I'm going to do my own thing, bitch.
I took my a plus and said, I'm
going to do my own thing. Bitch.
We're not Brad Pitt or George Clooney
accepting our Golden Globe lifetime
achievement award, but guess what?
Millions of people are saying, hey,
how the fuck can we change the shift
that you're talking about on the rogue
insurance is the thing that people
like least about us when we're drunk,
we just compliment each other.
They're like, hey, Joe Rogan.
Joe Rogan sucks, but I've got
to say, can you try and go?
I've got to say, if Joe Rogan and I don't
get along, then the world will land.
No, we'll be fine. We'll all
be fine. As I've gotten older,
one of the things that I've really come
to grips with is in this really strange
way is that we, for this brief
glimpse that were awakened alive,
we're really just a blip in this
infinite number of blips and w what I,
everybody worries about
their own finite nature.
It's one of the things that troubles all
of us and I'm, I'm one of those people.
It's just impossible to avoid.
I think anybody that doesn't,
it's not troubled by
the idea that you know,
you only have a certain amount of days
and hours and minutes on this earth
before. Eventually this vehicle shuts
down and stops working. Like what?
What? What, what are the things
that are important to you,
why you're here and what's important you,
why are you here is trying to spread
what I would call harmony would,
I would try to call this,
this community communion with each other.
The ability to develop really honest,
friendly relationships and I
think a lot of what we have,
whether it's issues with Muslims or
whether it's issues with Christians or
whether it is,
I think a lot of the issues that we
have across the board with human beings,
with various ideologies is
a lack of communication,
a lack of understanding that at the end
of the day we're like each other more
than we're different and what separates
us and what what you're talking about.
And the good thing about having financial
independence is that once you have
financial independence,
it releases you in a way
that's indescribable.
The people that are caught up in the,
the constant, very common web of,
of, of existence. It's
fired existence. It's hard.
I had a developments yard when I was,
I was 26 years old and I got a development
deal to come to California and do
this television show. And
when I, when I got it,
I got to check and it was a flick for
like $150,000 or something along those
lines. And immediately it was
like the whole world just,
just relaxed. Like I knew, you know,
my rent was like 600 bucks
or something like that.
I knew I could pay my rent now.
I knew I could eat now. I knew,
I knew I made 500 bucks in the
average week doing stand up.
I knew I could eat, I could pay my rent,
I could eat. And it was like this. Whoa.
And I remember sitting in my shitty
apartment in new Rochelle, New York,
and I had this weird epiphany when
that happened. I was like, Whoa,
this is like the biggest relief
I've ever had in my life.
Not I'm not rich by anybody's standards,
but all of a sudden now I'm a,
I'm slightly ahead of the run. And
again, I can stop and I can really,
I could look at the struggle
behind me and I'm like, oh,
we're caught up and we're caught
up in the momentum of debt.
We're caught up in the momentum of stress.
We're caught up in the momentum of having
to every this and that and every week
worry about did they
gonna shut my lights out,
all my cable bill fucking writing checks
and all that stupid shit that people do
all day. And as soon as you
can step away from that,
then you start to look at your life
and going like, what is my life like?
This just constant worry about this
impending tide of bills and pushing them
back.
Yes.
So
the one thing,
the responsibility that I think a person
like you has or a person like I have,
is that once you are slightly ahead of
that wave to let people know what it's
like, let people know what's going
on up here. And also let people know,
like you're being misled. This
doesn't last forever. The a sled,
that the whole thing, knowing your,
because we're all being misled.
You're saying what you're
saying is a hundred
I was so caught up in bills and money
and buy him shit and not buying shit and
being broke for so long that I got a,
I got consumed about cash and you're
exactly right when you have this.
It could be a hundred grand, it could be
whatever. It could be. Vegas could be,
I doesn't matter what it is.
But you get it and then you go,
oh all that time I spent worrying about
it all that time I was freaked out all
that time.
Like it's just a construct.
We make it up it money.
Is it just a bunch of fucking computer
fucking blips on the screen and then when
you get it you realize, and
this is Aye. Aye. Aye. Aye.
Aye. Aye. I know how
arrogant it is to say,
but at the same time you're like fuck
like all that time cause I'm stupid.
All that time I was
trying to chase the money.
I should have been trying
to chase something else. I
don't think I'll tell you,
but hold on.
I'll tell you what I mean,
because you know Spike Jones,
who I love more than anything,
you know,
he made adaptation being John
Malcovich every fucking award,
winning music, video, every award,
winning fucking commodity. Everyone most,
most and Eddie Kansas flow was I doing,
I was trying to make money.
We actually want to,
I'm one of our go to the mountain things.
It was like take money out of the
equation. What would you be doing?
And you know what I said I'd be doing
news cause that's the only shit that I
really like doing anymore.
Guess what I did after that?
I started news channel and news is stupid.
He can't make money. You can't
do thing. It's not gonna work.
You can't start a new news channel.
We're the fastest growing news
channel in the fucking world, Joe.
Yeah, but why? Why does everybody
say you can't make money in the news?
Cause everyone's dumb. But everyone
will tell you, you can't do something.
We've talked about this before.
Everyone will tell you you can't
do something to tell you do it.
And then they'll say, I always knew
you could do it. But the thing is,
is because it's difficult to do.
We have,
we're bigger than NBC and CBS
News, uh, combined on our online,
uh,
viewership or the largest and
growing news agency in the world.
Everyone told me I would fail.
Every single person without fail,
without exception,
told me I would fail.
The reason why we didn't is because
everyone's doing such a shitty job were
telling us that the images, but I
will say this about spike. He said,
take money out of the equation. What
would you do? Assign going to do news.
He goes, if that's what's gonna
get you up in the morning,
go to fucking news and tell
everyone else would go to hell,
which is what I've been doing,
which is why we've been getting a little
bit of trouble because now it was like,
I like vice news and I don't like the
other vice anymore. But there you go.
People like vice news where
they don't like the other vice.
Well because vice when we came up
was like Poopoo Caca in the book.
Crazy vice provides, you know, and now
the robot naked, that kind of shit. Yeah.
But now news became so big overnight,
vice news and vice are now fighting
each other for being how big they are.
And so now know like people are like,
I don't want to see people
khaki in the bump moms,
or I don't want to see your music shit
or your travel shit. And I'm like,
well then just turn into vice news.
Don't turn and do the other shit.
But the fact is this news
became so fucking big that
it's now coloring the rest
of the brand because the rest of the
brand needs to be used to be everything.
And now everybody just wants fucking
news. Which by the way, I love news,
but I still like all the other shit too.
You know the problem is it's not
even everybody that's complaining.
That's not really the problem.
The problem is access.
The problem is you shouldn't have 300
million in America plus worldwide have
access to just throw Twitter comments
up and Facebook comments and youtube
comments because I'll come, even
though it's not bad, it's not bad,
but it's overwhelming in the sense that
it's very, very difficult to manage.
It's almost impossible
to manage those numbers.
So you're going to get people
that complain. Some of them was,
some of their complaints are legitimate
and some of their complaints are just to
get your attention and the best way to
get your attention to tell you you're
shitting the bed. You're
fucking up. You're doing badly.
You're disappointing them.
It's not as good as the old device.
The old vice was better. I'll tell
you two things about that and the,
and that's exactly right. No, but
I'll tell you two things about that.
I'll get a hundred things and
you're changing the world.
You're changing newsroom.
And one thing saying you fucking
cock sucking cock sucker,
all fucking meet you at 59th and
seventh I'll kick your ass. So A,
B,
and this hits on.
All right,
well I dunno about you,
but about me and my life is that
you sit there and you say, you know,
I, I started, I had a small
company before and, and,
and it was 10 people in a
room and you're like, Joe,
or you got the fucking photo and
fucking Ted. Do you have the thing?
And fucking Rosalia and now we're doing
something on the order of 14,000 posts
today. And everyone's like, shame,
did you fucking see what fucking Vice
Bulgaria put up in that Goddamn bullshit?
And Germany just said that, this and
that and whatever else. And you're like,
I'm sorry,
but I'm lucky if I see posts a day and
we do 14,000 and that's the problem with
running something is that
you go when it was just me,
it's easy when it becomes,
I don't know how many people even
have 4,000 employees, some shit.
You're like doing 14,000 posts.
It sucks.
And I've got to say like when it,
when it is just you,
it's you and, but then, then
it's not advice then it's
not a thing. It's just me.
And,
and you know what I'm trying to do now
or what vice is trying to do now is to
have much more of a cohesive point
of view. And, and ironically,
how we're going to do that is we're
buying TV networks around the world.
We're going to make TV shows with them.
We then push up for the first time
ever day and date with, with uh,
an online and mobile.
No one's ever done it before and we
believe we'll have the largest uh, uh,
audience in the world online,
collectively online, mobile and TV.
And then the question is,
okay, great, what are you going
to put in there? What you,
we don't want to put it in shit just
between the ads. We're like, okay,
who wants like all over the people that
the spikes and the harmonies and the use
and the whoever else.
Now we're saying like we can put whatever
the fuck we want out to the largest
audience in the world.
We just don't want to put shit out there
because why the fuck are we getting out
of bed in the morning and that is going
to be our 2015 and that is why I believe
I'm positive because I'm going to
give it a shot. I might fuck up,
I might not do a good job,
but at least I'm going to have that
shot and we're going to go out.
We're going to try to do
something that doesn't suck.
Well,
there's a bunch of people that will
complain about anybody in any position of
power that is either above them
or has more influence in them.
But if there's a person that you, you
would be like, oh, that guy got it.
It was a person that would be,
I would be relaxed in a position to
disseminate information. It'll be you.
And again,
this is more of what most people hate
about the show is us sucking each other's
dicks. But you're a,
you're a genuine gangster.
I know you do all this crazy shit even
though you have money and you can do
whatever you want. You don't cow town and
you don't suck up to the corporations.
And it's weird as the
position that you're in is,
I wouldn't want anybody else doing it
other than neo because most people would
play it safe.
I gotta say one thing.
When we announced anything big,
we'll announce it on Joe Rogan. Why I'd
be on hold on. Why? Cause literally,
and we've said it before and I would
challenge somebody to watch the directory
of these podcasts because we're going
to launch one of the largest TV networks
in the world. We'll launch it on the Joe
Rogan show. Why? Because we're the same.
Why the fuck would we launch it on
today's show or whatever the fuck it is or
who the fuck cares? And by the way, you
only live once. We work with our friends,
we do with our friends. And by the
way, we are the new audience. Oh I,
I'm one thing I'd like to save for anyone
who gives a shit because I think for a
hundred people who say fucking
Rogan and Shane doing stuff is good.
When people say you're
so self congratulatory,
the reason why is
because Joe's a real guy.
This is a real fucking dude
came fucking up. I'm a real guy.
We came up and half of it
is us looking around going,
can you fucking believe this shit?
Can you believe where we are today?
We're sitting here having a conversation
with two mutual fucking dudes would
just have anyway, and millions of
people are listening to us on guests,
but we're going to announce the fucking,
the next wave of media in
the world together. Why?
Because we can and guess what?
If we don't celebrate that we're the
first fucking generation that's ever doing
that, then we should fuck off.
I Dunno. I'm getting weird. No,
you're not getting signals.
I'm getting fucking weird thing was
black for a second there on the screen,
but I look not just to be a human being.
The fact that you and I are having this
conversation to freakazoids who would
never be on anything any fucking other
way. I'm even if we get in shit for it,
I'm going to say it every time because
if I'm going to ever do anything in,
announce anything I'm going to
do on the rogue and show why.
Cause Joe Rogan is the fucking
man and because guess what?
I love him and that's all the fuck up
each other again. I try to avoid them
done. Now I'm over. Everyone can fuck off.
The world's about 10 it's not.
We're going to be okay, but I,
I see what you're saying and it sort
of aligns with what I'm saying is that
where we find ourselves in very unique
positions that we didn't expect to be in
and those positions happened
because it was just all,
everything along.
I don't need to do this podcast.
You don't need to do this podcast.
Why the fuck do you do this, Bob?
I want to have a conversation
like this with you.
If you and I had a conversation
at a restaurant, if we had a,
it would be 15 to 20 minutes of
your insane trips about the world.
We would laugh, we would tell
jokes, but there's an awareness.
The fact that this being broadcast that
makes us stay on point and focus on some
and occasionally a little dick sucking
every now and then something, but I don't,
I don't like that whole
Dick Sucking thing.
Not that I don't like Dick Sucking
criticisms of us. What? Hold on.
I would say the hundred people saying,
I love the the Rogan podcast
versus the one Dick sucker.
The one thing I would just like to say
is what I'm doing is saying that this is
the first time in media history or
conversations like this can happen and I
don't think that's fucking
Dick Sucking on it.
I think because of a lack of censorship
and that's one of the most important
theories about what's going on
there. There you go. Exactly.
Don't don't criticize people,
Zack,
you think they got it wrong with their
take or their humor, their satire. No.
Criticize the people that are
trying to silence dissent,
that are trying to silence
other people's criticism.
Satire criticized those people.
Don't criticize the people
that were making cartoons or
we should celebrate the fact that two
motherfuckers can sit there and go out
there
and say whatever the fuck they want
and people can listen or not listen,
and it's never happened before. This
is very rare. Never happened before.
Not only that, anyone can do this.
Any guy right now who has an iPhone,
I mean Dunkin, I and Ari and I,
we've done many podcasts on planes.
When we're sitting next to each other,
well,
one of the one of us will hold the phone
up in between the armrest and we'll
just talk and we'll have
a podcast on a plane.
You know what the also the big
difference is hundreds of thousands,
if not millions of people are out there.
It used to be, maybe it's three, four,
five, six. This is now a movement.
And that's why like whenever I come here,
I have to go see fucking Rogan.
Why a we're friends be I love your family.
See like I don't want to
go talk to anybody else.
I don't give a fuck about anybody else.
So I'm not,
I'm going to stop with the Dick Sucking.
But,
but I would like to say this is the
celebration of free speech and I give you
total Kudos because you don't
have to fucking do this.
You don't have to pay for this
place and do all this stuff. Yeah.
But I'm always blown away that you do
and I'll stop there. That's very nice.
But I do because anyone who couldn't
but all of a sudden was given the
opportunity would,
and that's exactly the situation I find
myself in and all of it is played out
for all of us in a, in a very unique way
that none of us could have planned out,
including just the average person that
is on Facebook or Twitter that sends a
message that you respond to or I respond
to or anybody Dunkin or anyone responds
to.
We're in this weird error of [inaudible]
that's never existed before and we were
a part of it as much as anyone else and
were a part of it and that we represent
that even though you,
you know,
you do make a a lot of money
or you do pay a lot of taxes,
you still are just a regular person and
you will continue to do those stories
that you find fascinating and
in need of illumination. Yeah.
These all these stories, whether it's your
story and you, you went to North Korea,
your riches, fuck, you
didn't have to go there.
You did that because this was compelling
and this was also something that you
felt like needed to be illuminated, but
you also have to look at you and, and,
and say, okay, you know, where's,
where's everyone else doing that?
Whereas Brad Pitt or what he's doing,
his own thing, I mean Brad Pitt
is, he adopts a lot of calories,
but who's actually paying money out of
their own pocket to create a studio to
have dialogue. And by
the way, I will say this,
the only thing that really fucking
matters in this world is dialogue.
We have to talk about shit. And if we
stopped talking about shit, we're dead.
And you know, you might not agree with
me, you might agree with me, whatever,
but at least we can come here. We
can talk about shit. But you know,
if you can't talk about shit
or the way you're talking,
this is what's really important and this
is what's really resonating with people
that are listening to this podcast or
watching it. We're talking in a way,
I mean, I joked around about
Anderson Cooper. He's seems
like a nice guy. He's gay.
He's probably been fucked with his
whole life. He's probably fine.
I bet if you sit down with them,
he's fine.
I bet a good percentage of the shield he
puts up is just to try to keep his job
as a gay albino and a fucking white
man's world. You know what I mean?
But the reality is that guy can't do this.
Well if Shane,
if Shane Smith wants to go out and have
his own podcast and you do it in a sumo
diaper,
one of those crazy sumo diapers and you
have all these Thai lady boys around you
and you're drinking fucking drinks
with umbrellas in it and your, your,
your smoking big spliffs but you're still
talking about the world and important
points, people will still
listen. You know why?
Because you're being what is absolutely
100% lacking in all of corporate
controlled media and that is
authentic. Well, what's missing?
I will say this,
I don't know Anderson Cooper and I
don't know most of these lives in our
firehouse, but, but what I will say is,
and this is a big deal
for me anyways personally,
is we were in negotiations
with Time Warner and we were
in negotiation and a lot
of people and uh, you know, I
could have made a lot of money.
They want an Anderson Cooper and you'd
go on a cruise. That would be no problem.
I'll go on a cruise with anyone know what
w like what are the thing is everyone
wants control. Right? And I
fought very hard to keep control.
I don't even know why. Quite frankly
that's, that's beyond because this is,
it goes back to the one day you wake up
and say, I got the money. I won the game.
What the fuck am I doing?
Why am I fighting so hard for control?
I vote 95% of the board and
largest single shareholder advice.
Why did I do that? Why didn't I take
money off the board and spend it? I'm not,
by the way, I'm not setting myself up. I
don't know the answer to that question,
but at least for now I
run fucking vice now.
I don't run it perfectly because a lot
of shit gets through that shouldn't get
through and a lot of things happen that
shouldn't happen cause I don't have
enough time in the day and
there's a bottleneck and I
have to get better at that.
But the thing is is I was able
to launch vice news by myself.
I was able to launch a vice. He was,
we're up for Peabody's and poachers.
I just wanted to the Knight
Foundation Award for Journalism,
which is great and I never
had heard of that shit.
Well I was trying to start a party.
I was trying to talk to a girl,
but she was like, yeah, I just won
that night ward for Knight Foundation,
Cock suckers. In any case, what I'm trying
to be, I'm trying to do a humble brag,
but what I'm trying to say is,
what I'm trying to say is I could do that.
I could say, you know what?
I'm going to override my board.
I'm going to override everybody going
override my investors and I'm going to
invest in news when everyone says you
shouldn't because there's no money to be
made news. Which is true, but
guess what? We did it. Why?
Because it's fucking important.
You're a guy.
You don't have to do any of this shit.
You're in fucking Hollywood.
You're celebrated motherfucker.
You can come out here and you can not
do fucking anything and fucking kill it.
Now what I'd like to say is you got to
medium old guys here who like a fucking
few drinks and by the way were regular
dudes who just grew up and said, hey,
I watch Scooby doo when I was young and
then I did this and I did that and now
we're just sitting here that said,
I believe that we're in the majority.
I believe that us and people
like us are in the majority.
And then we look and shit now and say,
hold on a second,
all these old motherfuckers are dying
off. We control this country. Now,
not only this country, but probably,
you know, the West, you know,
with our money and with our politics,
why are we still doing all this shitty
stuff? The only guy that does it,
we can weak out and says,
why are we still doing the shitty
stuff is fucking Joe Rogan.
Now Anderson Cooper, what he does is sits
there and says, here's the storm here,
or whatever there.
So sort of weatherman. He's a
weatherman. So for me, by the way,
I'll tell you what I'll
tell you right now, Fox,
CNN up the ass and fuck
all mainstream media.
Fuck Fox News up the ass.
But what I will say is we'll at least try,
I'm not going to just say fuck CNN
and not try to be better than them.
I believe in the first eight months
of vice that we were better than CNN.
We're up for all the awards, right?
We are rating better than CNN.
And by the way, we're not doing
it great. We're not perfect.
We're not fucking doing a great, but
we're going to get there now, certainly,
you know, you know we fucking
broke Ebola. We broke all isis.
We were the first in Ukraine.
We were the Fox first and guys,
but guess who the fucking people.
I'm going to go talk about that.
What does you fuck CNN and fuck 60
minutes that they had their time.
So rude.
I can't be a part of this because I was
about to do a deal with Larry King to
relaunch Larry King lives
fine, but he's gone. He's,
he's going to do his own thing.
That's why I'm on the Internet now.
He should do his own thing an mean.
It's probably should do their own thing.
But if we found that they get more,
he gets more views using the internet
than he ever did, but he will though.
He will probably, he
will. Of course he was.
We just got somebody behind
them with some shackles.
Give them some growth hormones.
I would,
I would back him except for the
fact that he's fucking oldest.
[inaudible] we're all going
to be fucking old. Well,
I'm not going to be a holding.
He was old and he was Timothy leary.
You'd back them. I don't know.
I'm not an old gangster. Yeah.
You think so?
Yeah.
Don't you think that somewhere along
the line science will save you.
Science will step in and just shut
the liver. Regeneration. Peggy,
give Shane a shot and lose their
breast. I'd either liver cancer, peace
and I was like,
I will literally give you all my money
if you can fucking care my liver cancer
because excuse me.
And I know it's in the mail cause I like
to drink booze and I gotta tell you I
like to drink booze or it food.
I like to sleep. I'm essential.
Sensualist you like senses? I like
sensual. I think. Yeah. Who doesn't?
I want to find that fine.
Have you ever been an experience?
I want to find that guy wants be known.
Ah, Robin and cane on his dick all day.
Who is he? That guy. You only live once
and then you're dead for a long time.
That's what I'm saying, Dawg. Fuck
all those people that disagree.
Sensory experiences.
One of the beautiful things about life,
the greatest thing about life is life.
Enjoy your fucking shit
no matter what it is.
And then you're going to be dead
for a long time. So just do it.
The more the older I get,
the more I'm just like,
I'm going to enjoy the shit out of this
motherfucker. That's what I'm saying.
Yeah. The older I get, the
of the mortality this is,
that's set this God damn thing
on fire and go. When I was 20,
I didn't think it was going to
end when I was 30. I was like,
this shit's going to end way in the
future when I'm 40. I'm like, Hey,
when does this end now I'm 47. I'm like,
um, how much time do I have left? Those,
those are the, the, the steps,
the mortality of the 20s is staggering
to me now because I used to,
I used to just think it's all going to go
on for it. Well, I have a buddy and uh,
he, he called me once
and he goes, you know,
what's the scariest fucking thing in
the world? Teenage boys. Oh fuck. Yeah.
And I go, why? He goes, well, I was the
scariest. Yeah. He goes, they don't know.
They don't know.
They can,
they want to make a name and they want
to fuck shit up and smash shit. Yeah.
And it's true and I think that that's one
of the weird things about life is that
no one comes out of the box with any
sort of understanding of what the,
the grand spectrum of this experience is.
The scariest thing in
life is teenage boys done.
Cause they don't give a fuck. I was a
teenage boy and I would fuck the shit up.
And every time, I mean, if you, doesn't
matter if you're in Africa, Afghanistan,
whatever, if you see a bunch of
teenage kids with guns, you're fucked.
If you see a guy with a gray beard,
you're like, I can talk to this guy.
Talk to this guy. Yeah,
no, you, he's right.
That's the scariest thing in
life is teenage. Well, intro
in, in understanding of that or
in, in consideration of that,
the scariest thing in life is really
ignorance is power and ignorance together.
And when you're 18 and where
you and you're a young man,
your idea of what you you can
accomplish once you start getting laid.
Once you win your first
fistfight, once you, you know,
you're at the top of the
world, it's like you, you,
you get into this
experience in life where,
because of the limited amount of
information that you've been exposed to,
the limited amount of
people that you've met,
the limited amount of friends
that you've had, you start,
you start forming your world
and your world is so small.
It's so tiny.
But you think because of the limited
amount of experience that you have,
you think that this is what's up.
We'd live living in New York too.
Long time. They're all fucked.
Fake eyelash surely can't talk as Joe
Rogan smokes, the strongest bond left,
but you're right. Speed we
represent. I think that the,
you were exactly right
in that when I was young,
I would tell you,
I knew what the fuck I was talking about.
I would tell you I understood mortality.
I would tell you all this shit,
but the fact of the matter is,
no matter how bad the fight or how drunk
I was driving my car home or jumping
off the bridge into the water or all
the stupid shit I did when I was young,
in the back of my mind,
I believed that I would never die.
And even because I hung out with this
gang of kids and a bunch of them died from
drug overdoses and a bunch of
them die from car accidents
and he says, said, shit,
there's nothing sadder than a teenager
die. But the thing is is quite frankly,
they all died from the boring shit.
They all died from you got wasted
and you fucking hit the car.
You got fucking wasted to use
overdose or whatever the fuck it is.
And you look at it now and go,
you know how much you missed, man,
you know how much of all this crazy
fucking shit you didn't get to see.
You know? And at that
point you're like, look,
I was the dumbest mother fucker on
earth when I left home at 14 and I got
progressively dumber until I was probably
in my mid twenties and I think when
mortality comes and gets you,
and this is, I dunno about you,
but it's hit me,
is every day is fucking awesome.
You know,
I,
I see the worst shit in the world everyday
with politics and with poverty and
with the environment, whatever
the fuck it is. But guess what?
Fucking life.
This is fucking awesome. If
you're healthy, life is amazing.
If you're a healthy life is,
you're healthy,
if you're healthy and you have friends,
that's the big one.
That's why solitary confinement
is the darkest shit of all time.
Hold on. And this goes back to our first
point. If you're out to be healthy,
you're right, you got to, you know, have
friends, family, somebody's out there.
You know, you got to enjoy your
shit. You know, enjoy your food,
enjoy your fucking sleep and joy,
your book, whatever the fuck it is.
But the other thing is,
is if you don't have future,
if you don't have like I
tomorrow's going to be good too.
You know,
then you're fucked.
And that's why we all have to
participate in that shit. Sorry I
caught you off guard. It's
inevitable. I mean we're,
we're all participating because
it's inevitable. I mean we're,
we're all a part of
this crazy growing wave.
Okay,
I'm going to have become addicted
to your, it's good for you, dude.
Don't be scared it a life.
It's going to just calm me down
and soothe you and relax your soul.
But if had,
if I had you all over again,
I would realize that every day is fucking
just, I think you will have to kill it.
I think if you had to
do it all over again,
you do it exactly the same
because if you didn't,
you would never learn the lessons
that you learned. You know? I mean,
I'm not claiming that I've
gone the perfect path, but I,
I, every fucking disaster I've ever been
a part of, every mistake I've ever made.
It's made me humble, reconsider,
or be more considerate,
be more introspective, be more
observant, be more objective.
It's just look at it from, you
have to fuck up. You can't,
everybody that fucks up,
they feel like they're a bad person
cause they fucked up. But no,
you're just a person.
Hopefully you didn't fuck up too bad.
That's how you learn by fucking
up. Yeah. It's a bit when it, when,
when you're killing it, you're like,
Oh yeah, I'm smart in some of the best.
Exactly what you learn by
fucking up. That's what people
hate, right? What do we,
what do we hate more than anything?
We hate cockiness, right? Yeah.
It's one of those. But yeah, people
hate more than anything, which is yes,
it's true. And I've learned that the
hard way because I like being cocky.
I like guys, I like saying I'm going to
fucking kill it. And I'm like, other guys,
I like beat guys go and say,
and they're going to come if they don't,
that's coming. Whatever.
That's bro. No, but I do,
I like people being confident and
going out there and doing that shit.
It's Bible. Well, my old man always
said to me when I was young, he goes,
they're going to tell you life is fair.
That's not true.
He goes,
life is brutal.
You have to be the smartest
and the toughest and you
have to win and you have to
be there in the right
place at the right time.
Even then if you have a little
Dick, you're fucked. Well,
cause I have a huge dick you that
didn't come into it. But no, he,
it was just like he was,
he was,
he was like honest
because that's the truth.
It's fucking hard. Yeah, it's hard.
And you have to have a
little bit of luck as well.
And everyone off tells their kids, it's
fine, it's good, it's gonna be great.
And my old man was like anxious
going to be fucking hard.
So you better really fucking tried to
hit it because if you get fucked up,
it's only going to travel with you.
And at that point you're,
you sit there and go, honesty
goes a long way. We're are wasted.
We should probably go.
And I got to get them
best ending of a podcast
ever a long drunk and rent.
And we should probably get
out of here because it's only
gonna get worse from now on for me.
Shane's bad mother fucker. You,
every time we talk, I feel inspired.
You're a bad mother fucker, dude. The next
time we were, we have a rule, a new rule.
Next podcast. It be no complimenting
each other, either one at all. Done.
I love you, but it's enough.
Enough already. We're getting
ridiculous. Uh, you're,
you're the best man. I appreciate you
very much. Appreciate you very much.
I appreciate you coming out to.
Thank you. All right fuckers.
We'll be right back in about 10 minutes
with the Great Ari Shaffir bull pin it.
I got an RS holder on that.